Experience.
I missed the English broad.
You got to bring her back eventually.
The Joe Rogan experience English though.
That sounds like,
isn't there an English version of it where it's got more of an English site or
how high was I when I heard it?
You might might've been just talks to me.
She was very proper.
The Joe Rogan experience.
Can we do that?
Sure.
I get a real check to do it.
Hey Rory,
what's up buddy?
Hey Joe.
How are you doing this man?
I appreciate it and seriously,
I really appreciate you having me,
dude.
You have a fucking amazing story.
You have a Hollywood success story.
It's,
it's the,
it's pretty get this thing up to your face so you could hear it feels good.
He'd be,
that's what I'm saying.
Can I get another one on my other sheet?
Fucking everywhere would have put them all over you.
Sweet man.
The two you up at to turn that off for a second.
I've got to do something.
No,
I,
it's,
it's very,
uh,
on Hollywood in the sense that I was in New York and working at the daily show,
which is next to the horse stables for central park.
Yeah.
I should say it's a great show Biz story.
I guess so.
Yeah.
It went from being like a PA to the executive producer of the daily show and
that's fucking awesome.
Yeah.
Well it was good.
It was not the,
uh,
I didn't know that that was going to happen.
I got a job,
wanted to do comedy,
I wanted to do standup,
but I went to college,
so I felt weird coming out of college and tell my parents I was just going to be
competing and you know,
like remember all that money and stuff.
Like I'm just going to tell jokes like my,
I come from like,
my dad is like an old school Italian guy.
Like he doesn't understand this kind of stuff.
He's like,
what?
What about a job?
You know what I mean?
Like get a job.
Like he would've been happier if I said I was going to be a,
like a mailman or an electrician like that would have made more sense than a job
in TV.
So we're comedy in general.
So I got the job here in like that could at least justify the love of comedy.
That's sort,
it makes sense.
Like look,
I'm working in the serious business.
Yeah.
Leave television shows were very successful.
Or at least I had to go somewhere.
Do you know,
on a Friday.
I think that was a big part of it.
It was like,
well what do you do when the morning when the alarm was on?
Oh you don't have to get up in the morning cause you just the work at night and
comedy clubs comes like what?
Yeah,
the comics that we know that don't do anything during the day.
I mean they just fuck off completely until they get on stage.
Which I'm always quite jealous though actually.
You know,
I,
but I always had that feeling when people go,
how do you do both?
I'm like,
well,
you know,
once during the day,
so that's one way to do both though.
As I got older,
I got more tired at night and it's harder to go out and do clubs after the daily
show.
It is.
Right.
It's the hardest thing in the world when you,
when you're on a set.
I'm not the hardest thing in the world.
I shouldn't
look compared to anything else.
It's really easy.
It's as easy as fuck.
But I mean it's hard to work.
What I was going to say,
it's the hardest thing in the world to work a full time job and then try to go
out and pursue something because you're all your,
your juice has gone.
It's like,
yeah,
if you're,
I mean,
anything you're trying to do that's like athletes that have full time jobs,
like fighters that have full time jobs.
Fuck,
that's hard.
And that's even harder because they have hours of training they have to put in
every day.
But just when you're done at the end of the day,
you're done.
You want to get a bite to eat,
watch TV since you don't want to go over your notes and fucking for me,
the other thing was too is still not even at a place where like I walk in with
club and they're like,
oh,
just get right up.
And it's,
it's,
you know,
usually they're like,
why don't you clean up this mess at 1:30 AM,
you know?
Um,
but I,
so for me it was a lot of,
it was just I loved doing the time,
but sometimes you got to hang out at the club and then,
you know,
it's like,
yeah,
my bigger problem was,
cause then I have fun hanging out with other comics and I have afterwards,
I have a couple of drinks.
Next thing I know,
like the harder problem was getting up the next morning and three hours.
So that's where I started to have that.
Uh,
you know,
while I'm doing,
the thing that was good about my day job is it got me better at comedy,
so I didn't really lose the like sort of experience.
I think I would've gotten on stage.
Um,
what I didn't get by doing it every night for a while was a,
you know,
like a seasoned onstage.
It took me a little longer to get like comfortable on you.
Get back into the groove.
Yeah,
exactly.
Yeah.
But uh,
still,
uh,
it was a good experience.
Pa to EPA was fun.
That's amazing.
That's one of those stories that you're going to ruin the expectations for every
fucking kid who,
everyone there.
Honestly,
I have to say at the daily show because it's been on so long at John's such a
cool guy and like really gave people opportunities there.
Um,
I was among the first people to kind of make that journey,
but now have not been the only one.
That writer there was a PA that's amazing.
Bunch of the EPA,
the eps and Coley p's and stuff were Peter's.
Yeah.
Like,
wow,
people can come.
It's like,
you know,
that's like a farm system almost for good writing and producing.
It's pretty cool.
That's fantastic.
Yeah.
And it's become like for a lot of people how they get the news.
That's a problem.
Isn't that weird?
Like that.
That's how people get the new John Stewart.
Yeah.
People tell me that a lot.
Say,
well that's where I got my news and I get it.
Like I remember being in college,
we go to college,
kids get their news.
I feel like I didn't even watch the news when I was in college.
Like I don't know.
You're in college,
you know?
So I guess it's better than nothing.
But uh,
I always tell people it's a good place to start to get interested in a topic and
then go off and do your own research or whatever you want.
Because when people get into political debates off of like emails and like daily
show clips and they're like,
that's actually not true.
It's like,
you know,
they don't have like a real understanding of each story necessarily,
you know?
Yeah.
It's weird thing,
isn't it?
When you're,
when you're,
when you're doing a television show that's also an educational show and also has
like a very progressive point of view of what you would think of when you think
of John Stewart.
Just like very intelligent,
very progressive mocking of both the left and the right when they do ridiculous
shit.
Yeah.
But it's gotta be funny for sure.
I mean that's a hard job.
Yeah.
Well it's really hard for him.
For me it was a lot easier cause I got to watch him do it.
Right.
I mean that's the thing about John that's amazing is he does all,
he's involved from 9:00 AM through the end of the show obviously when he hosted
it.
But in other words she so intimately involved and he's so smart and so sharp
that like when he's in the chair I never worried about a joke not working
because even when they didn't work he just would like call an audible and his
own head and then like remember a joke from like the 90 and meeting that he
liked that didn't make the script and throw that in or it's pretty amazing to
watch him to sitting in the studio because he'll change a joke in prompter as a
prompter scrolling and then later there's a callback to the joke.
He changed and he remembers to change the callback or skip the call val.
And I'm like,
and I'm sitting there with the script watching the prompter going,
oh no.
I'm like,
oh no,
here comes to call back like we're screwed,
you know?
And then he's just jumps it or,
or,
or tags that with the jokey.
It's,
it's amazing.
Yeah.
It's really like watching [inaudible] been doing it for that long too.
I mean,
he's fucking smooth.
He's so used to that Gig.
Like for Jimmy Fallon or me for Seth Meyers who tried the same sort of impromptu
ad Lib.
They might pull it off,
but Jon Stewart's been doing it forever.
Yeah.
Forever and ever.
Oh,
no doubt.
And he also,
uh,
yeah,
he just,
and he also just knows a lot.
He was a good comic too.
Yeah.
He's a great comic,
but he also just knows,
um,
he understands comedy in a way that,
I'm sure those,
uh,
you know,
I know both Seth and Jimmy,
Super Funny Guy,
I just never worked with him in that capacity.
So I know John understands it,
like music,
you know what I'm saying?
Oh No,
that won't work.
This will work.
You know,
and people go,
how do you know something's going to work before you try it?
And it's like you just kind of know.
I don't know.
You just kind of know.
Well,
he also has a very specific voice.
He knows his voice and his style of delivery.
Absolutely.
It's,
um,
it's,
it's an,
it's a fascinating show because it's very political,
but yet very funny.
It's,
he doesn't sacrifice like going for funny.
Yeah.
Like to try to look like less silly or try to look dignified.
He's not trying to monologue it.
Yeah.
No,
he's just making this stuff.
It's funny as you can and sometimes he gets extremely animated and it's fucking
hilarious.
Yeah.
I mean he's,
he's,
he's versatile in that sense.
Like he can really do and he tied comedy.
Yeah.
And uh,
but yeah,
as far as it,
I think it's,
cause it really is,
and people,
there's always bothers people so much that was going to go,
oh,
what they think the daily show that can agenda.
It's like we're all sitting around in a circle be like,
how do we screw the right?
You know,
it's like,
no it doesn't.
It's people don't believe that.
And they go,
Oh,
you're just hiding behind the fact that it's a comedy show.
He's got no doing comedy is really hard.
There's nothing a hot like we still have to take the stories.
We still tried to get everything right.
We have people who fact check.
There's a guy there named Adam maciato coffee.
It was like just a guru of information
and we'll come in to the rewrite room between rehearsal and the show after we
changed the joke and I go,
you can't say this this way cause it's statistically inaccurate to like
sometimes I'm like,
yeah man,
no one's going to care.
I can't say that,
but I'm saying it's not even a,
it was a,
we're,
so,
we really fact check stuff that goes out,
but the,
you know,
so it really,
a big part of the day is figuring out how to tell the story,
the narrative,
and then adding the jokes is why you have,
you know,
writers and guys like John,
then you can pile on the funny,
but funny is the most important thing.
There really is.
That's what's so fun.
That's why I stayed so long because it's not like a,
I dunno,
that's,
there's no like movement happening.
There's just a comedy show.
Well,
that's why everybody who gets so attached to it,
it's so crazy.
It's like they want it almost to be more ideologically driven than it is.
Yeah.
It's like people would,
they would want it if he said something ridiculous,
supportive and supportive of Obama there would like it.
But if Obama fucks up,
he goes after him too all the time.
Yeah.
I mean that's the thing.
Uh,
the show really became what it is or what people think of it as now during the
Bush administration.
So I think people really associated being this like hardcore left wing a show
and it definitely slants left.
I mean it's hard sometimes for it not to with in comedy because everything
that's when you're pointing out some things are just straight up absurd.
Yeah.
It's hard sometimes not to seem left because you're throwing away like,
you know,
so I think that's why people go,
why don't people do a right wing daily show?
It's like,
it's not really a left or right thing.
It's just a lot of times comedy is dismissive of people taking themselves too
seriously.
And Conservatives have a tendency to take things very seriously.
You know what I'm saying?
That's exactly what they are.
They're conservative,
more centered.
Comic by nature is the guy sitting in the back of the classroom being like,
look at his dick.
You know,
like you don't really care what the person's saying.
You're just finding places to get a laugh.
And I think so for us,
like when the left does it sort of things,
which is also quite frequent.
Like occupy Wall Street was a perfect example of my favorite times at the daily
show.
Well we're like ripping the left and new asshole and the audience,
cause I'm in the studio where it used to be.
And the audience is like,
what are you guys doing man John,
this is our movement man.
And he's,
you know,
the zip up their zip,
he's over there,
John Stewart for president t shirts,
you know,
they're like,
oh shit.
And for me it was like we crush those dudes and then I'd go to the desk between
commercials and we'd be like,
yeah,
you know,
it's a standups mentality.
Like do you feel the crowd?
Like I just came back from Madison,
Wisconsin this weekend and it's an amazing city.
Like the club is awesome.
The shows were so fun,
but they were,
it was grown.
They were groans from the crowd on certain things.
I would say cause it was this college town and colleges now are really like,
I know that's like a,
a taboo right wing thing to say,
but there's a left wing
political correctness in college now that is an extreme extreme.
And I remember like 10 years ago doing a college gig is very different than now.
You make a joke about being like,
whoa.
And that was happening in Madison and there's,
you know as a comic,
right?
Like you feel that from the crowd and you go,
wait,
what just happened?
Yeah.
And then you know,
you want to like poke it a little bit.
So on the daily show,
John's a comic,
but we hit it when we hit a note on something.
We were going after Hillary in her weight.
Same thing.
Go.
What do you guys do it?
I don't know.
Doing what we do and making fun of people who are in charge.
Like you know,
it's,
sorry you don't,
it's selective outrage,
you know?
Well,
it's one of the more interesting things that's happened during the transition
between the Bush administration and the Obama administration is that people are
starting to deny this whole party thing.
They're starting to go look at this is where,
okay we're getting fucked here.
This is not a left or right.
So lead ideas that everybody in the right subscribes to.
Like immediately you tell someone you're a republican and they immediately think
you've got some freaky ideas about gay marriage.
You're a pro war,
you're antiabortion.
They just start throwing things like you automatically get tossed into a very
extreme category.
Or if you say,
I only vote Democrat,
you'll automatically get bunched in with these bleeding hearts.
Super ridiculous professional victims,
just the most ridiculous social policies.
You get two extremes on two sides and there's no room for nuance and the idea
that you were either one or the other,
it's kind of being exposed as being ridiculous now that that's it.
It's so funny that you say that cause that's literally like the thing that's
obsessed.
I'm obsessed with since I left the show and that's why I've been talking about
my standard backed.
It's like we're giving two choices and as you pick a box and then that's what
you feel about every issue in that column.
And you're like,
well wait a minute,
what if I'm pro choice but I'm okay with guns,
right?
What do I do?
Do I,
you can't,
you're not allowed.
You're not allowed left where you can be.
Right.
And like you said,
nuance I that's just called thinking like in other words,
whatever happened to like something comes up and people,
smart people sit around and talk about it and think about it instead of going
knee jerk knee jerk.
If this happens to the right's going to get this.
It's so odd and I don't understand how I,
and I agree with you,
I don't think most people feel that way,
but I think the people who have a voice on TV,
a word media I should say are picking sides.
So it's like you're just sort of getting clumped into one of those too.
There's a real issue with that for sure.
There's a real issue with the people that are running these shows.
Also taking safe choices.
That's a real issue.
Like if you're easy to define,
but how the fuck did guns and gay marriage get put in the same group?
How come they're even remotely connected?
Yeah.
Like you can be pro gay marriage and you have to not want a gun.
Yeah,
you can own a gun.
That's what I'm saying.
I don't,
I don't see that.
I don't see the connection,
the bizarre connections.
Those are connections,
conservative and progressive connection sometimes don't make any sense at all.
Well I also think too,
um,
especially
now,
you know,
the argument against guns,
and I'm not saying I don't own a gun,
but I'm not,
I understand why people do,
you know,
I don't know.
Again,
cause I live in New York City and like it's just not a good place to open carry.
You know,
he's not,
you know what,
you don't want to cruise around Manhattan with a three 57.
And you know,
Anthony Mia actually does carry a gun with him everywhere in New York because in
New York you're really not allowed to carry a weapon.
He has a concealed carry permit.
National?
No,
he has a New York one.
Wow.
Yeah.
He cost him a lot of money and a lot of times,
but that's what a bribe like some Staten Island people to get.
One of them brought up what he had.
You got to go to an ad of borrow bribes house.
The secret poker.
Yeah.
I don't know.
I don't know how they got school.
Like New York Shit.
He's also a public figure.
He's,
I'm sure he's had death threats,
worries about safety.
But he,
he,
you know,
the whole story with him getting kicked off the air.
No,
he got an who's taking photographs like four o'clock in the morning in New York
and some woman to beat him up.
Some chick he took a picture of and uh,
he was,
he had a gun on him the entire time.
And then he went on this tirade about the pro,
the crime problem and black America,
you know,
the violence problem in black man.
They fired him from opie and Anthony just,
just giant outrage,
outrage on both sides.
But the point being this guy had a gun on him.
He has a gun on him all the time,
like,
and he did nothing with it.
He did nothing with it.
He wasn't,
he said he wasn't in danger.
She was,
he was just,
she was hitting him,
but it was,
it sucked.
But,
but in Florida,
that person gets shot every time,
you know,
it's Florida just to comp this conversation alone could get you shot.
Did you guys talk about somebody get in a fight?
I'm shooting somebody shooting somebody and they're pretty sure there's a
loophole,
but I definitely don't think everybody should have a gun.
I definitely used to be hard to get a gun.
I think you still have to,
they should have to.
I mean we should all agree on what the requirements are.
But mental health requirements,
if she'd give you a mental health evaluation,
to me the gun issue,
it was always just been like wha what's so in order in order to go scuba diving,
he got to take a class I a test,
you know,
and that's just so you don't like come up too fast.
They get the bends or what it was like in order to get a car,
which everyone says is a weapon,
you know,
if you drive drunk or whatever,
it's a weapon and you got a hot,
might go to jail for homicide.
If you killed somebody in a car drunk or whatever,
um,
you got to get a tea,
take a task,
get a license.
I to me it's just like guns were fine,
but why not just you,
you pass the handgun class,
get a handgun and you registered.
To me it's just about like no one who's getting the guns.
Cause then at some point someone's like,
I want to take the Bazooka class and you're like we should watch that guy.
You know what I mean?
The Guy,
the guy who wants to take the Bazooka class.
It seems like,
you know,
maybe he gets on a list,
I dunno where he does it,
you know,
I don't want to piss people.
I don't want a guy with a bazooka finding me.
But they're going to get mad at you right now.
Even just suggesting that.
No,
but I'm just saying a class to me seems like a reasonable seems very reasonable.
But again,
I get it.
It's like you know the country,
but then I think about this a lot.
The Second Amendment,
the argument is you,
it's different now.
The is an ancient document.
People used to have muskets,
now they have ar fifteens but the same is true with the first amendment because
people used to just stand and like a town square and yell stuff.
They wanted to get off their chest.
But now we've got Twitter,
which is like the Ar 15 of free speech and it's like now you've got crazy people
putting shit out there,
you know,
with,
so it's the same thing.
Well,
maybe we've got a scale that thing back a bit to what you can do in the name of
parody.
Like there's all these websites to just write fake stories and these fake
stories aren't even funny.
They're just totally fake.
Right.
And people retweet them and tweak them and you'd go to the website says
somewhere in the website,
this is a parody site.
And they're like,
oh,
he's like a right wing onion.
You know?
It's like not funny,
unbelievably bad.
And those are the ones like my mom sends me,
she's like,
did you see this?
Did you see this?
This is what all Muslim people are like.
I'm like,
that's not,
it's actually not that.
That's a photo shopped thing.
You know,
like that's cause then that little,
there's a,
there's a mom forwarding community.
I think the gun argument is that if you,
if you make it so that people have to take a mental health evaluation,
the,
the real extreme guys would say,
well then someone is going to decide who gets to absence and that'll be
political and ideologically driven and the left,
we'll make sure that no one is mentally capable of carrying a gun.
Yeah.
Well that's why I was saying I don't think it's a mental health thing.
I just think it's like a road test that that's all I'm saying.
Like it should be both.
Right?
I mean I just feel that thing than a car because it's not transportation.
It's only purpose is to shoot things,
but,
but uh,
Eh,
yeah,
I guess it's only purpose is,
but it's a hot number for some people.
It's a hobby.
For some people they like to go to a shooting range.
They like to shoot.
They're entitled to like to do that just like a bow and arrow.
You don't even need a license.
Right.
Stolen.
Now,
which is also a,
I guess,
and even a crossbow.
Yeah.
Crossbows just goes,
things are crazy.
Are you allowed to wear a cross bows like just around your question?
Question does it really?
Good question.
It would be cool as shit to do.
I think there's a limit on what size blade you can have for a knife.
But I wonder if like a weapon liquor walking around a city with a quiver.
It's bad.
You should look into that.
I mean I'm sure you can use arrowheads.
We can have them tied to a stick.
Arrowhead tied to a stick.
I mean you can have a boat like if he and Steve using arrows like with real like
sharp like ends.
You can use an arrowhead cause that's,
that's a rock.
Well Arrowhead.
What do you mean there's arrowheads?
You know,
you find like ancient Indian ones.
Oh say like take a piece of Flint as a weapon though.
Yeah,
that's a weapon.
That's a weapon still.
That was a solid weapon for centuries actually.
I mean you can't,
you can't deny that arrowhead is this designed specifically to kill time.
So if you get pulled over with a bunch of arrowheads,
you're in trouble.
Well you could if you were attached to an actual device,
like a stick,
like if you had a spear and you're in your car,
like a real spear that was tied down with like animals,
sinew and shiny fucking bleed.
Hang it across the back
of your yeah,
I like those caveman ones.
I see.
Know what is it called obsidian?
Is that what it is?
Weird.
It's like a blackrock.
Yeah.
Shiny rock.
It's that slices up nice when you chip away at it.
Yeah.
That,
that's probably the line.
But you can say like,
Hey,
I'm just into archeology and,
or I'm 12 and I found it outside.
Isn't it funny?
You could still find those in some places.
I found one when I was a kid in Ohio.
Did you really?
I guess it was a very common because I,
and uh,
because there was this like place old man's cave,
old man's cave and it is really a place called old man's cave.
Jeepers creepers
told his mask off and it's really the fucking town after all,
it's a young lady.
I remember the one night,
the one I found was broken.
So,
but,
but you can tell it was like the tip or the like half of one.
Oh Wow.
That's so cool.
I would love to find something like that that,
you know,
somebody used for sure hundreds and hundreds of years ago and you just holding
onto it,
trying to think about what time was passed.
Very cool.
Check out.
This is old man's cave.
It really is a place.
Yeah.
And it's just,
it's just like,
no dude.
That's young ladies Gulch.
I know.
I know my way around.
No,
that's a dope fucking cool.
You found an arrowhead there?
Yeah.
There's a waterfall and there's tons of old man's cave is bad ass.
Cool.
That's so cool.
Wow.
And then there's like insights where you go inside,
there's like slag Mites,
stalag tights,
stalag tights to lag might and select type.
Have you ever seen that fucking spot that they found in Mexico that looks like
member,
um,
uh,
Superman's dad.
He had that crazy island Morley.
Brandon.
He'd had a crazy island.
Yeah.
Doc Driver Brando was,
his dad was his dad.
I remember he had that crazy place where they would go and there was all the ice
crystals and shit.
It looked really nutty.
Fortunate,
some solid shot it.
Yeah.
There's a place in Mexico that looks like a real live fortress of solitude.
Pull,
pull it up,
pull up fortress of solitude in Mexico,
crystal caves,
crystal caves in Mexico where there's they're crystals and they're are fucking
huge.
Giant once all over the place and it doesn't even look real and it's apparently
insanely hot down there.
Like you can't even stay down there for very long while you're examining it
because it's like 140 a hundred just go right.
You're cooking in Mexico and this and these.
These things.
Look at this.
This is real shit.
These,
those are people,
man.
That's a fucking dude.
These are,
those are soft science.
Crazy walking on top of these giant beams of crestal.
Wow.
That's crazy.
It's fucking insane.
Those crystals are 40 50 feet long.
Some of them even more.
Look at that one.
That's like a hundred feet long that it's crazy and they're giant around and you
could walk on them.
They're like bridges.
That's amazing.
Yeah.
There's a bunch of dope pictures,
dude.
If you,
if you find some other ones,
some of them they just don't even look real like you see these people standing
here like it.
We'll get that one with a two.
Right?
Oh my God,
that's a same,
that's just when it,
when they light it up,
did you know that they found that through some insane amount of water that was
hidden in the earth's surface and it's in stuff like that.
It's in a mineral.
They found that there's way more water in the in the earth and they,
they recently,
then they realized,
I'm sure we'll find a way to suck it out and use it for something.
I think it's in like some sort of a mineral form.
It's a many times more than ocean and all the oceans.
Yeah.
We talked about trying to just pull it up.
It's a huge underground reservoir holds three times as much water as in the
oceans.
How fucking crazy is that?
It's that kind of shit.
It's like it's,
it's not actually water.
I don't think the way it was like minerals or whatever.
Yeah,
it's,
it's something,
something that it's called Ringwood night and it's only been found in a media
rights.
That's crazy.
That's what this fucking shit is.
I think that's it.
And they believe that a,
like a lot of the water,
they believe that hit earth came from probably scientist right now.
Listen to me going,
what?
You don't know what the fuck you're saying?
Stupid.
I don't,
but what was it?
A lot of the blessed meteors I'll,
a lot of the water on this earth came from comments.
That's what they think.
I think that,
um,
that a lot of the water just came from space.
Just like when you see a comment in those big trails behind the comment.
Apparently that's water vapor,
but that was energy drink.
That's what I,
that's monster came from.
Yeah.
So,
um,
I don't know how we got on this.
How did we get on this one water?
If arrowheads rarely go arrowheads.
Oh,
we were talking about,
we're talking about guns.
Yeah,
we went somewhere.
We went to old man's cave.
Old Man's cave.
Oh,
that's when you got to crystal caves in Mexico.
The Crystal Caves in Mexico.
He has someone like j Lo got a,
a bathtub carved out,
a crystal from Mexico,
some,
some high high cloud quality baller.
And it was like a million dollar bathtub.
Wow.
It was just carved a Mexican crystals.
Awesome man.
That's totally necessary.
I just don't know why they didn't use it,
if at all.
There's no diamonds in it.
Have to,
I think having a bath tub is a waste of money,
let alone a crystal bad cause you're not a chick.
That's right.
So that's cause I don't eat.
Yeah,
they love to have their leg up in the air,
like the shot of getting into a pool of standing water to clean myself.
There's nothing about that.
That seems to really,
well at the end of the day you really just sitting and,
but soup.
Yeah,
It's all wash it on my,
but I want to be in a shower unless you take a shower first and then take your
disgusting.
Yeah.
Like you're just,
you're just,
you're watering down the amount of health on your body.
That's all you're doing.
You're spreading it out evenly.
You're just bringing but juice all over your
brass and his feet very quickly.
Trademark budgets.
I don't know if that's out there,
the amount.
I mean if you are not a good wiper,
the amount of shit material that's still in your ass.
If you were about to take a nice clean bath tub and someone said,
okay,
I'm just going to give a one 16th of a teaspoon of shit and stirred in the
water,
but like get the fuck out of here.
I'm not getting in that water.
That's exactly what you're doing.
I think one second take a teaspoon is is,
is low based on top of people know some of the,
basically if you're Harry from some Italian guy with a big fucking area bay area
and then that's 2% shit in that dirty,
disgusting.
Yeah.
Bathroom fucking weird man.
It's like a,
it's a relaxation thing as much as it is a bathing thing,
we know how to do shout with it.
They invented them when these to have to like heat up water is they just stuff
with fire under them.
That's one of the reasons why they were iron.
Well it's also,
it also used to be like people took baths in the same water.
Yeah.
Cause you don't want to lug that water from the lake.
$100 or the river.
You know what I mean?
And then it would be like,
all right,
mom goes first.
You know what I mean by the end
at that point,
like you know,
and I'm good,
I'm good on the bathroom.
I bet they never got sick.
They're just trading each others back and forth.
Then pooping in the,
well you know the poop in the woods,
I says saying they never got sick.
It's ridiculous because not only did they get sick but they died like millions
of minutes time.
One fluid hit,
people die,
died from like diarrhea all the time.
Yeah.
Dysentery.
That scares the shit out of me about this Ebola thing that they can't,
they can't contain it and they keep spreading.
They can't contain it.
If you've been reading those stories,
like they can't contain it in Africa,
but some of the,
some of what's happening in those villages is people are not telling that the,
first of all there's no,
there's no like CDC,
they're like kind of controlling the situation.
Like it's a,
it's a mess internally within the country,
but also with the people aren't,
a lot of people are scared.
Like it's,
it's just a different culture so people are scared.
There was one doctor who is from the region who study here at like Harvard and
he was back there now and he wrote this thing about it,
just saying they did an article on him just saying how his biggest struggle is
convincing people in these villages that they need to take these warnings
seriously and things like that.
There's all of these other components of a,
besides the fact that the disease is just spreading rapidly,
but the people aren't reacting properly,
you know what I mean?
That makes sense.
So there's like more,
and I'm not saying it's not a terrible thing,
I just mean there was more to it there.
They're structurally disorganized.
It seems like there's people who are like not telling them that there were so
and so died two days before.
They're like,
and there's no nine one one like ambulances don't come.
They're not clearing the bodies out in time.
Like it's a V it's not a first world situation.
You know I told which is serious problem on a whole other level,
but it's,
it's one of the reasons it's difficult to control.
Isn't that like a plot and a movie like does,
isn't that how the super disease spreads?
It spreads through like a series of things that you as you're watching the
movie,
you'll go,
no,
don't tell him that the light,
the Lady's Dad,
it's not going to tell him the mosquitoes in your pants.
It's in your pants.
Is He zips up
slap.
Yeah Man,
it's Africa scary.
It scares the shit out of me.
It's a weird,
the more I read about different parts of Africa,
I mean there's obviously Johannesburg and there's some cities and I've met a lot
of people from South Africa that are cool as fuck,
but the whole of Africa is so fucking huge.
If you look at like when you look at a map,
we look at a map,
we look at Africa as if Africa is the same size America.
Cause on maps they're kind of distorted.
Have you ever seen that image when they put America inside of Africa and you get
to see how big Africa really is?
Yeah.
It's fucking monstrous and it's where everything started yet and you can't,
don't say that.
What do you mean on the air?
What do you mean without Jesus?
Well I mean stuff that wold on Adam was a white dude.
He had his rib pick them out.
I can grind a couple of weeks.
I believe in Adam and Eve really believes in it or like,
like instantaneous.
That's how people came here.
Really.
Incest.
Yup.
Cause that,
that,
that's always confused me.
I was like they have a kid and then they have another kid and they,
those foods for kids or the kids fuck each other.
If someone's getting fucked,
you have to make people make like nobody wants to hear that you say that,
that frank and Susan down the street at least,
you know,
give them the spread out the DNA a little bit,
come on.
I know you work in mysterious ways,
but come on,
we'll know ahead to do it again to start all over again with Noah saying same
deal.
And he also had all those animals to fuck to,
no,
I'm going to be made.
We probably couldn't fuck the animals cause he's,
she had to fuck his kids and make sure he made more kids.
Am I going to make people,
he could not save those loads.
He was 500 years old.
I really felt that that should have been the Russell Crowe movie and just him
fucking his kids.
You know what I mean?
Just two hours of Russell Crowe fucking his daughter while the fucking into
moving rock monster's guard over them.
Yeah.
I liked the Hollywood executives.
It's got to like make me one of them kid fucking movies.
I could a Bible
listen if they have a better explanation,
but them right to them.
Write the script,
hire a couple of Jews,
pick me a kid fucking movie diet than the Old Testament.
The New Testament.
I don't give a shit.
Could you imagine if you pitched a movie where Adam and Eve hadn't have sex with
her children because they realized it was the only way for for children to
survive.
So Adam and eve could be played by like Brad Pitt.
Got to be and like a someone hot.
I think it would be girl girlfriend.
Kickass.
Which ones that she's too young anymore.
How about like 20 Brad Pitt?
Kathy Bates fucking blow people's minds.
I'm scared of Kathy Bates after misery.
I wouldn't be able to jerk off to that movie.
Well
that's,
those are your movie reviews.
Joe Rogan says he whack into it.
I tried hard his Joe Rogan of the Wacky at times.
Speaking of whacking a strange movies man I saw under the skin with a scarlet
Johansson this weekend.
And you seen it?
No,
I didn't know anything about it.
It's an art movie that they made with her in Scotland where they used hidden
cameras and she tried to pick up men.
Oh,
it's like Scarlett Johannsen.
She just,
she had an English accent.
I don't know if she has an English accent in real life.
Real.
In other words,
a lot of it is real interactions with random people and they want to be using
them in their interactions with her.
In the movie,
the movie's about her.
She's an alien.
She comes here and tries to emulate human beings and when she emulates human
beings,
she takes men,
and I don't want to give away the plot,
but she lures them in with her beautiful,
good looks and charm and she's naked and half the movie,
it's fucking fantastic.
Hold on,
let me write this.
Because of that,
she's naked and have to move in.
You know what I love about her man?
She's naked and she's not thin now.
She's,
she's,
she's a woman.
She's a sexy woman.
Like I fucking hate that women think that they have to look for it.
They're starving to death.
They're attractive.
Drives me nuts and so cell and also,
um,
did you see don?
Don,
John,
is that what it's called?
With a,
no,
I didn't see that and see that she as like a long island.
It was really funny.
Yeah.
It's funny.
But I was like a long island like east coast kind of dude.
That movie to me like hit so many funny points.
Like just him driving around yelling at people get fuck it.
I was like,
yeah,
that's how you drive.
Like that's a normal way.
And that scarlet Johannson though she plays like this Italian girl,
Italian girl chewing gum and she's like,
I love your parents.
You know,
like it's awesome.
Goes over for Sunday dinner.
Like oh it's so funny.
That's so funny.
But she's that character.
My friends always make fun of me cause like those long island girls,
like I have such a weakness for that kind of a girl.
Yo.
Yeah.
Cause it's like,
it's like Kryptonite for me.
Like I,
even though I,
you know,
I don't know,
it's just like it's,
that's what I grew up around.
So sometimes I'll see a girl like that.
I'm just like,
Yay,
she's laid back.
I don't know.
It's just like,
you know,
like half a girl when you were a kid that like,
like a Joan jet type thing.
What?
Joan Jett lived in my town for a while,
so that's could be part of it.
Yeah.
I don't know.
It's just weird.
It's my front.
My buddies from college,
I always to make fun of me.
Like they used to say cocky,
like that girl's Kilkee,
you know,
like from New York and like,
Hey,
she is,
and be like,
oh Rah ree.
I'm like,
yeah,
say it again.
I'm so the opposite.
Yeah.
Well,
I mean,
I believe me,
I've not really been with too many girls like that,
but there's like a,
I have an impulsive reaction.
Like that girl's attractive.
Like,
cause that's what you grow up around.
Yeah,
I hear that accident.
I think arguments.
Yeah,
arguments are coming.
Sure.
But isn't that half the fun?
Not me,
man.
You're not good at those.
I don't enjoy those.
Especially interrelational arguments,
you know,
I don't mind arguing with drunk idiots.
No,
she didn't want to argue with the chick.
I'm was fighting in a relationships
of worst thing in the world.
Especially as you get older,
you get so tired,
you're like,
yeah,
fine,
yeah I don't whatever.
But also you start realizing,
hey,
how come I never argued with this with my friends?
You know,
like what's going on there?
Like I had an ex girlfriend a long time ago back in the Disney who just loved
fucking fight and one that one day I was hanging out with,
one of my friends were laughing and joking around and I realized I go,
why is it that when you were around like certain people it just becomes tense
and fighting.
It's not their fault.
It's not your fault.
It's like you just need to not be hanging around with those people.
Like that kind of person.
Like she'll find a god that she could steam roll and she'll have a grand old
time and maybe he'll enjoy that type of relationship too.
But this is not right for you.
Well that's what it is.
I think it's also,
a lot of it is just personality.
Like I have a very,
like I want to be in control of my own shit kind of person.
And I've been day two people.
I was married at one point.
Yeah.
Which is a whole other course.
But uh,
but yeah,
I think it,
but I don't even think it's bad when you realize that that's an in
compatibility.
I think there's a reality that,
which is like,
we're going to be conflicting all the way through this and like what's,
you know,
at some point you just go like,
I'm crazy about this person.
But like there seems to be a disconnect in my ability to agree and your ability
to agree with each other on things because we both want to go right away and
there's not absolutes and these types of relationships.
Sometimes people can just figure it out and work it out.
Yeah.
Just communicate with each other and make things better.
And sometimes I can't,
you know,
it's like when you talk about these things whenever you like,
it sounds like giving advice,
relationship advice.
People will always get pissed off one way or another.
They're always like,
you're judging or you're this or you're that.
But the reality is who the fuck knows what?
It's like the idea of a man and a woman finding the exact right compatibility
for each other is so fucking hard to do.
So when people like will,
they think they have to break up and they know they have to break up.
Like,
Goddamn it,
we fight all the time.
We got to fucking break up.
It's hard to just start all over again.
It's really,
that's what people are scared of.
People were scared of getting out of the bad one and then trying to find a good
one because it's fucking hard to find cool people.
There's also a comfort in a relationship that even then when you're fighting,
yeah,
there's a comfort to it and like you got to separate the like,
I dunno man,
we both like American idol.
You know,
you gotta like you gotta try to separate some of that and go like the other
stuff that's happening.
He's not healthy.
I've had my best relationships with checks.
I have zero in common with just the lungs.
We're nice to each other.
Yeah.
Like I don't need to like the kind of music you like.
I can walk in and go,
what the fuck are you listening to?
But I don't get upset.
Well that's the whole thing.
As long as they don't care.
Cause then sometimes people are like,
oh you disrespect my shows.
You're like,
well there's some guys that like,
you know,
I want my girls started going to the gym with me.
She gonna start power lifting.
Like what?
That's a weird request.
Knowing that I wanted to understand a lifestyle that's amazing.
It's going to be more girls.
I think you're attractive but you don't really have traps,
you know,
work on your neck muscle.
She goes skinny now.
A little bit of too much neck.
I don't think it's so hot.
Like some less.
I'm a girl.
I would have ringworm on that finger.
How did we get on the subject of Scroll Johansen's movie?
I don't know.
You were on the airplane watching it.
We were talking about other movies before that,
right?
I don't know.
Do we always have to figure out how we got on this stuff.
Now,
unfortunately,
I have to know if series this is,
this is typical me.
I got a notepad in front of me,
these legal notepads,
but when I have something I don't want to forget,
I'll write it down and I'm like,
I'm not going to forget that I didn't write it down.
The story of my standup writing.
I'm like,
that's a good bit.
Oh,
write it down tomorrow.
You know?
Now I'm going to walk.
Keep playing this video game.
You ever hear of Mitch Hedberg joke about that?
A paraphrasing,
but it goes sometimes when I'm lying in bed,
I have the idea for a joke.
Either I have a pen or a pad or af to convince myself that it wasn't that funny.
That's exactly right.
He's so good.
He's,
yeah,
he was be awesome.
It's shit that this doesn't look funny on paper and you're crying laughing.
He's one of those comments.
I saw one.
I have the chance to see live once and a boy.
I remember watching him going,
well,
I don't,
I don't know why I'm doing this.
She was one of those,
we're just going,
what's the point?
Like that guy's out there,
you know,
and so unique.
There's no Mitch Hedberg,
you know,
it's like Mitch Hedberg and that's it.
There's no one,
he's like,
he,
there's guys who are like Mitch Hedberg now,
but when I put him in a category,
he's like a unique little branch and his,
just his,
yeah.
The whole thing with him,
his delivery,
his style,
his performance,
just,
you never really saw his face kind of hair in front of is so sad that that guy
had such a fucking raging drug problem that we lost him at such a young age.
Same with Geraldo,
man.
That,
that crushed me and kind of some incredible Geraldo.
It's more of like a onetime accident.
Yeah,
no,
I know,
but he did.
He was struggling and he was going to do shit.
But yeah,
it was definitely not as,
it was not like Mitch Hedberg.
The rumor was like this guys,
well,
he was almost going to lose his leg like we were when we were,
um,
Doug and I were working together and he got this phone call and he hung up the
phone.
His face was Ashen and he's like,
a Hedberg might lose his leg.
Jesus cried.
I was like,
no fucking way.
And they're like,
hey,
he's hospitalized.
He apparently had been shooting into the same vein over and over and over again,
and it was just,
it was awful infected.
And you know,
when Stan hope was saying it,
I was like,
is like,
it's almost more fucked than hearing about a gun dying is hearing about a guy
gets his leg amputated because he was doing heroin too much.
Especially now like gang grains.
That's a crazy,
yeah.
That's something like Roman times hit it right before he died too,
right?
Yeah.
It was about a year before he died.
I think so,
um,
when,
you know,
Doug was pretty close to them.
I only met him once.
Man,
I only met him once at the store.
I went on after him one night at the store.
He was really cool.
He's very friendly.
But I,
I've always been a fan always in since then.
Um,
I actually was listening to one of his albums just like two or three days ago.
Yes.
Crace great.
It's even stuff that didn't work when it didn't work.
He just had this way of going that one needs,
it was something,
you know,
something along those lines.
His,
his delivery.
Yeah.
So that didn't go how I yeah,
that's true.
Will not be on the CD.
Just amazing.
The doubletree joke about how they name their fuck what,
you know,
what do you want to name the hotel?
Two trees.
No,
doubletree.
I like it.
Meeting adjourn.
I'm paraphrasing.
That's it.
Yeah.
Second to second suggestion.
They were over at the second session.
Yeah.
He would pick apart like casual phrases and make them really hilarious.
He was a fucking brilliant guy.
Yeah.
Awesome guy.
You know,
I always wonder,
and this is the unfortunate thing about when a guy,
cause like I know how much marijuana has helped me and helped me.
Right.
And I'm not,
I,
I'm not shy to admit it.
I think like when I write and I write,
when I'm on weed,
I write things that I would never have come up with on my own.
I really do believe that.
It sounds crazy.
Maybe I would have,
I come up with some things on my own,
my own,
but it's almost like weed is your ghost writer and I see a guy like him and I
wonder like what?
What,
how much of that was just being on heroin?
I don't know.
That's a good question.
But I do think with weed or writing on weed,
I think that you can come up with,
I don't know.
I think you are capable as capable as coming up with maybe different jokes but
good jokes without being on weed or being on weed.
But maybe like,
I mean I think about that sometimes too.
Like it,
I like smoking pot and going,
Oh man,
like this idea.
I would never thought of it.
But then sometimes the next day when I read it I'm like,
yeah,
it's not really that good fucking.
Last night I was like,
I think I'm like,
and then I picked her myself and like a billboard company money.
Like he did it,
the billion dollar
cover of Forbes.
Like we'd like to Jaguars in a Jaguar,
you know,
to heading,
he's got three pit cheetahs cause fuck it.
You know,
cause he came up with one idea.
Exactly.
That's always what I say.
People uh,
uh,
as like you,
when you start doing standup,
there's always that you or that thing you think is gonna happen this moment
where like that's it.
Yeah.
Because it used to be like people would go on Carson,
you know,
or whatever.
And uh,
and then you realize,
oh no,
it's just as long journey of like trying to get better at this craft and like,
yeah,
there's no way you ever feel like you made it if you're still working too.
Yeah.
Cause you're still,
you're always working on it.
Yeah.
Especially as a comic.
You're fucking,
you're always working on it.
You have to be like,
yeah,
you have to continue to go on stage.
Can't,
can't take six months off here and there and stop touring.
And then you've got to constantly be doing it.
Yup.
And what I leave or at least constantly be writing and thinking about it and
like always ready to go
out and try stuff.
For sure.
Yeah.
I mean for sure.
And I think a guy like Hedberg,
like he was just getting,
people were just starting to catch on to how amazing that cause what happened
with Hicks too,
when people were just starting to hear about him,
died set for,
that's the really sad,
I don't think,
I don't even think he probably had a clue what he started and also how he will
be forever consider.
I don't think he probably has an idea that he's regarded as one of the greats.
Maybe he does or doesn't,
but it's like,
I always think about that.
Like that is a guy that in the last 10 years his like his legend has only grown
materials still relevant,
which is really weird.
Even the stuff that people might not think is that funny.
It's very relevant.
Total day.
Yeah.
Maybe the the in the see the real problem is a lot of things that he said.
Everybody says no,
and they think,
oh,
what's the big deal?
Everybody says that.
But they don't realize that in 1992 everybody wasn't saying that.
Yeah.
It was just Hicks.
And it was the first time anybody was ever saying this shit that he said in a
standup form.
Like that young man on acid dude,
young man on acid and realizes that life is just,
I don't remember how I realize it's just,
it's like pointless journey.
It's a positive news story.
The idea was like,
why?
Why are they always just giving you only negative news stories?
Yeah.
And then,
you know,
his take on the Iraq war,
I mean,
he,
he basically had material from then that could be used still truly today.
Carlin's the same way with them and stuff.
Like he does a special,
my favorite George Carlin special was jamming in New York.
What?
You didn't like 92,
I think,
or 1990,
92 around then.
And uh,
he has stuff in that,
that about the environment that's as pertinent now as it was even more now,
particularly now because people are talking about it more.
But,
uh,
the Iraq war,
talking about Dick Cheney and the Iraq war,
like,
Shit,
that Le Verbatim translated,
uh,
talking about,
got to go play with her toys in the sand,
got to go play with her toys at this end.
You know what I mean?
And it's like,
it just talking about all of that stuff,
like we love war and just,
I'm not every 10 years we averaged a war in America and,
and saying things that are like not only funny but like blow your mind.
And then the environment is like,
I still believe his theory on the environment,
which is like people saying like,
save the Earth.
And he's like,
no,
there was fine.
Like we're fucked.
I mean,
and it's like when it's ready,
it'll shake us off like a bad case of fleas,
you know,
like we're a surface nuisance.
You know,
when you start paying attention to all the different mass extinctions that
they've been on earth,
they just pulled up some new evidence that shows the,
uh,
there was another comment that hit the earth way before the dinosaurs that was
mag thousands of times a bigger impact than the one that killed the dinosaurs
like a couple billion years ago.
Apparently we were hit by a planet.
Yeah,
that happens.
That's the earth,
you know,
that's just gets smashed.
You know,
that's the premise of a two of the greatest movies of all time.
A Armageddon and uh,
the other one,
what was the other impact he'd been people I was thinking Halley's comet impact.
They didn't even have to change the name for the porno now that they did not,
they didn't do it.
That's a,
that's a scary fucking image man of giant five foot,
five mile wide fucking chunk of rock that's going to slam into the earth and
kill everything.
I also think though that like any image of your own death is scary.
Of course.
You know,
like you don't know how it's coming.
Nobody,
everyone thinks it's,
it'd be like 90 and laying in bed and like their grandkids will be like tickling
their feet,
you know?
But like you don't fucking know.
Well,
even if it is while you were like in bed,
like people say I want to go with my sleep.
What if you go in your sleep and the nightmare is it the grim reaper is riding
your face,
choking you to death.
Yeah.
Screaming into your eyes.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
That's,
that's all the way to go out though.
That's a sign tattered and robes.
Somebody write that down.
I'm getting that Tattoo on you.
He's got glowing eyes getting that tattooed across my back.
The reaper.
Fuck him a face man.
Not fucking,
you're holding your,
you know your neck.
I didn't mean it's actually met.
He was just fucking going to town and I would have said,
I see what it said.
It was fucking,
you wake up at the horse cock and your mouth,
what's going on?
Slides and almost like a Roto rooter.
They start realizing why my resistance so much.
I don't mind this.
And that's how you die realizing cock last
shit.
It's like you can get fucked in the ass and your dreams,
but you can't die in your dreams.
Right?
I don't know.
I don't know if I've ever had an ass rape dream.
I can't say I have or even an ass sex dream.
Why are we saying rape?
We're not really saying rape.
The real nightmare would be that you loved it.
Oh,
I get what it did.
Or would that solve all my problems?
No,
I don't know.
I don't think,
I don't feel like,
I remember like being,
I guess I do still have sex dreams occasionally thought my dreams aren't like
fun anymore,
you know?
I don't know.
I used to have like fun ones where I was like in war and shit.
Now they're just more like,
I'm like,
I got to check email.
I'm really my like dreams are lame.
You know nothing about me is cool.
Yeah.
I had a dream last night that I cleaned up my office.
Fucking,
that's something like treats.
So I got up this morning and I cleaned up my office.
My dreams tried to tell him something.
I fucking Slob to get my shit together.
What does this mean?
Oh,
it just means you should clean your office actually stopped being a slob.
Pack rat boxes of Shit.
I got boxes.
I've got magazines from like the 80s like what am I going to read this again?
You should sell a male's magazine.
People like 1989
his desk,
I don't even know if it's from the 80s but it was old as fuck.
It was like stupid old.
That's funny.
I boxes of Shit.
She could buy that stuff.
All magazines,
there's a whole market and like my shit on fire.
I don't want them alive.
I don't want them to have it.
Remember you used to give me all posters.
He used to give me boxes of posters,
like just get rid of this Brian Ebay.
All these posters that I had from like the early days of the UFC.
I had pride posters that were there.
Probably very valuable.
Yeah,
they were.
I mean,
people were snatching them up as he like as he locks his BMW.
He was like,
yes,
they were.
Yeah.
Well they were quite valuable actually.
It was a lot of,
I just had to get rid of it and I felt the best way to do it.
Let him,
Hey,
go tell go.
Yeah.
There is a few of them that I almost wanted to keep because they were just cool
posters,
Barnwell and that pride Sperma it's pretty dope.
Black and blue.
One with the guy,
I can't remember.
It was quite a few.
The old uh,
Vito Belfort one that was one from like early UFC.
He's like,
yeah,
those are just,
that's,
that's interesting stuff.
But most of it is just bullshit.
Fucking old notebooks.
Right.
Open it up and I'd just go,
oh my keeping this war.
Did you ever read old material and go like,
oh man,
it's good.
It's always like,
wow,
this is so bad.
I'm like,
you know,
no wonder they didn't give me that spot on a in,
on whatever,
you know?
It's like,
oh yeah,
it wasn't,
that wasn't very good.
It seems like it should be way easier than it is to just figure out a way to
write a joke.
Yeah.
I find it,
the easiest thing to do is think of a concept of something I like,
write it down a little bit and then play with it on stage.
Cause I don't,
I don't,
I don't know.
I don't have like a,
a discipline writing process as much as I really like finding it on stage and
then trying to repeat it the next night if I can.
And you know,
it's a hard,
it's a bad way to do it in a lot of ways because you,
it takes sometimes longer to find the material.
But if I record it now,
I just recorded on my phone,
I can listen to a band guy.
I told that joke,
you know,
a certain way.
We were kind of talking about this earlier with that joke.
It's like I told a joke a perfect way that night and it killed and I can't
figure out what the fuck I did.
So now I liked being able to go back and listen to it and go,
oh I just pause there.
And then sometimes it's just I got lucky that one night and if they're not all
good,
I have the same process for sure.
I think a lot of people do,
but I also try to write stuff out sometimes to just,
you know what I try to do?
I tried to write like blog entries.
Yeah.
Most of all I never post but I write the blog entry and then in the blog entry I
find like a gem.
Yeah cause you just sorta writing.
Then you find and you pull that out.
That's like the same thing as riffing on stage.
You're just doing it with your fingers.
And I do that on my phone a lot.
I just go into the notes thing and I just jam out and think.
But then a lot of that like I'll read through it again.
I'm like,
I may have been stoned.
Like it's a sure.
Yeah.
It's like Ah,
this is,
I mean this is tenuous at best connection of making hair,
you know what I mean?
And then I realized,
I'm like,
I guarantee you there's a hundred books on that topic and I'm dumb.
This is not some brilliant new idea.
And then I'm like,
Yup,
there it is.
There's,
well there's always that right.
Especially when you think you have an interesting idea that nobody ever thought
of today.
You just Google it and you go,
oh look,
there's a whole forum dedicated to it.
Yeah,
that's actually a question I always have for other comics,
which is what is your,
cause I have had people come up to me at standup clubs both,
both ways,
but I've had people come and go,
hey man,
there was a comic down here,
you know like I mean in Atlanta or something,
some local guy or Austin.
And we look at,
and it was a comic down here.
He was doing a bit that you did in your half hour it looks.
So I just let them know.
I was like,
yeah that never do that.
It's okay.
And by the way,
you watch my half out.
You know what I mean?
Like I don't even know anyone saw that fucking thing.
But it's like the idea that somebody else wouldn't come home off premises
pumping look or you know,
just so you know,
Louis C k does stuff on airplanes.
Yeah.
There's only a hundred topics in the fucking world.
I can't call topics.
You know,
you can't call airplanes.
You know what I mean?
It's like,
and I don't think Louis was you,
I'm just saying like there was this weird thing now,
like this comedy police thing,
but at the same time I have seen,
I know you've dealt with it before,
comics straight up steal other people's stuff or maybe unintentionally,
but so it's going to be that in my hand.
It's always going to be people stealing.
But I do think with the Internet now,
it's really hard.
You know,
you do a joke,
this used sat,
but at the daily show come up with a joke until we look,
go Ashley Patton Oswald tweeted that like an hour ago.
It's like,
well,
what are we supposed to do?
Check everyone's Twitter.
Like we got to put a show on me.
Especially a topicals.
It's more just one person,
which is an obvious premise.
Yeah,
exactly.
It's like that happens sometimes on Twitter.
I write a joke,
someone goes,
oh,
you know,
you're 20 minutes behind selling.
So I'm like,
okay,
I don't know man.
Like I didn't,
I didn't steal it.
It's not,
I'm like both of our defense.
It's not that good.
It's a Twitter joke.
Yeah.
Well I think there's just,
there's always going to be parallel thinking,
but what people were really worried about is plagiarism.
And as long as it's not plagiarism,
I think you kind of know when it's plagiarism because it's never just one
instance.
Nobody was ever steals like one awesome bit.
Totally right.
And then everything else is totally original.
Yeah.
Well,
I,
you know,
the,
I'd never seen anything in my life.
Like somebody did the cut online of the men see a bill Cosby from bill Cosby.
It's awful.
I mean,
yeah,
that was,
that was astonishing.
Just that one.
No worries.
That was his whole career.
No,
I know.
And I,
you know,
and that was,
that was an interesting thing,
but you're right.
And I've had people say,
hey,
so and so does that then.
All right.
I won't do it.
You know,
there's a lot of people that want to take shortcuts for everything.
Absolutely.
You know,
they want to take shortcuts for every single thing there is.
And if there was a way that they could just take someone song and twist it
around a little bit and put it in a record and sell it.
This sounds like back in black.
No,
no,
no.
It's black and blue.
Black and blow.
And I mean there's,
there's fuckers that are like that man.
I don't know for sure.
Copy something and just sort of re rebrand it.
But you can't do that in music.
They'll fucking sue the shit out and they'll sue the shit out of you.
It's still doing comedy.
No,
you can't.
And I also think it's hard to,
I just,
I really do think it's more of just an honor system where you just do your best
to do your own stuff.
And I always say to people that go,
Oh,
you know what?
If someone steals a joke,
you know,
I don't know,
just write another one.
Like,
I don't know,
like if either you can write more or you can't.
Like if,
if the,
if the hour of stuff I was doing right now is the only hour I could ever come up
with then like,
right,
I'm wasting my time here.
You feel well,
the only thing I ever feel is there's a certain amount of responsibility you
have in saying something.
Because if you don't say something and then he steals from somebody else and he
doesn't say
something and he steals from you,
sort of almost help the problem.
If you don't,
if you don't at least have a dialogue with the guy,
cause you mean you may never know,
like you might say something to him and he might've never stolen anything in his
life and he might have not even known that you did it.
He might've heard somebody else say it somewhere and forgot and then come up
with it.
There's weird things that do happen.
When my friend Mike,
uh,
he,
oh,
he wasn't a thief who's young comic.
You fell asleep listening to a fucking Dennis Miller CD or a cassette at the
time.
And,
uh,
he was looking at when he's an open miker and then had this perfect Dennis
Miller joke the next day.
It's amazing.
And I go,
dude,
[inaudible] the place in Mozambique.
And he's like,
that's weird.
I think he was shaking my head from side to side with all my jokes.
Now it's,
hey,
don't wants a cup of Gus back check.
I think it was my grandfather who was when Reagan was president.
He's like Greg and 72 and he's got access to the button.
My grandfather is 72.
We don't let them use the remote control for the TV.
I mean he said it like just like Miller too.
I got to tell him and he's like,
fuck,
that's so fun.
I've had,
but that's happened to every comic.
I think at one point or another you've come up with this great idea and you're
like,
wait,
not now.
I think that's Ted Alexandro wait a bit.
Shit.
Yeah.
Oh.
Tells the best at that.
He's the best.
He'll like,
he'll call you up like in the middle of nowhere.
Hey,
have you ever heard those?
And they're like,
go run the joke by Ya.
Oh human.
He runs a,
yeah,
that's like,
have you heard anything like this before?
But they tend to easy tell is also one of those guys I find if I listened to too
much,
he's like,
well it can be just like one of my favorite comics.
Yeah.
And I find myself sometimes on set Quinn to column,
like those guys are working on with her,
you know?
And I'm like,
wait a minute,
that's not,
I shouldn't be doing that.
You know,
you know what you do to cure that.
You watch Brody Stevens and then you'll,
you'll start saying enjoy it and it will balance it out.
Like you get little real bro.
But he's the most addictive.
But,
uh,
I find myself doing Brody in real life,
what it tells us to take on stage where he'll say something and somebody gets
it,
pulls back and were like,
calm down.
Rebecca didn't know anyone's name or do you just make up names?
I fuck it.
You know,
he's like,
Oh look,
a tower over here.
Like he's one of those columns where I will occasionally have to walk out of the
room cause I don't like on like gagging for a,
he's so good.
But yeah,
if I hear it too much,
sure.
It gets,
you know,
can getting your hand.
You know what's funny about him too?
Man fucking hates everything he does.
Wow.
You talked to him about it.
He's like,
oh,
I fucking hate that.
I can't watch it.
I kind of watch myself.
Yeah,
yeah.
He's,
yeah,
he's,
I dunno.
I think that that's one of the reasons why he's so good.
Yeah.
I also think he's just kind of such like a purist.
He's like,
he's,
you know,
he's about as legit as you can be.
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
He's a legit standup comic,
you know,
when he's gotten really into kettle bells,
what really turned him onto that?
I don't think so.
I think some of the else Musta really know if we talked about it when he was on
the podcast,
but he still smokes,
but he's been lifting kettle bells.
I was really into it.
According to Ari.
Ari told me that Dave is actually from my hometown I tail.
Where's that raffle center?
Was Amy Schumer a lot long island?
Yeah,
it's raffle center.
What's that?
Needs a and it's like the south shore.
I near Garden City.
I'm trying to think of the towns.
People know ocean side.
What year did you start doing standup?
I started right when I got out of school.
I did my senior year of college.
I did a show in Boston 99 and then I got a job at the daily show basically right
out of school and I started doing standup.
Right.
Then 22 wow.
And were you doing like east side w that was east side,
wasn't around back then was what was doing any,
first of all I was already gone.
I don't think so.
No.
I was doing a Gotham,
Gotham bringer shows Gotham,
which were like you bring six puffs,
six people and they do them at like six 30 at night.
So we have a packed house and it's all new comics,
but you know,
it's basically asking your friends and family to pay for you to do standard
safety.
Do in La too.
Yeah.
And it's a smart thing for the club and it gives you a sense of what it's like
to be on a real stage.
It's a great,
I thought it was a great system and having been from New York,
I was able to get my five people occasionally.
But then after you do that four or five times really as well,
I,
this is not a sustainable business model,
you know what I mean?
Yeah.
Like as generous as it is you have,
you know?
Yeah.
But at some point you're like,
yeah,
I don't want to do every set I do and for my mom and dad cause I need somebody
to come,
you know?
And uh,
and then you start,
you know,
finding ways to get up.
In the beginning it was more,
I did more of producing my own shows.
I getting up at clubs in New York,
it's hard,
you know,
there's a lot of really like you're going up against like a tail.
You're like,
Hey,
I want to do 10 minutes.
And I tell like,
Nah,
that like first Louise coming in,
then a towel.
Then,
you know,
Ben,
but like you've got a lot of great standups living in New York,
going to those clubs.
So,
and it's easy to take a cab from club to club.
So I was doing a lot of producing my own stuff in bars and basements.
And then what you do is you barter stage time with the other guys.
Yeah.
So you're like,
I'll give you 10 minutes.
Am I,
you know,
it's a kind of like a comedy currency.
It was a great way to get up on stage and meet other comics and go to like
really shitty basements and do really weird shows and bar.
I went to the bar and W in white plains,
New York,
which is like north of the city,
it's like north of Yonkers.
And uh,
that was everyone's there hanging out,
watching a Yankee game and all of a sudden the bartender just shuts off all the
TVs and he's like,
everyone's,
what the fuck Tommy,
you know,
like local bond.
He's like comedy
generically points in my direction where I'm standing holding a mic.
And if it was like,
what?
And then I just had to be like,
so a,
hey,
have you guys taken the e train cross town?
Right.
What a nightmare.
You know,
they were like,
you know,
like,
I mean I've had a lot of those kinds of shows.
I do the exact same type of shows and Boston we used to do it,
uh,
at this place in Cape Cod is meeting this Guy Al Ducharme and some other dude I
forget.
And uh,
we were out there in the middle of nowhere in a hockey game was on it.
It's the same thing.
You shut off the fucking hockey gear.
Yeah.
To put up comedy.
It was death.
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
It's d and then it all it is then is an exercise in your ability to sustain
humiliation.
It's really all it is.
There's no,
there's no people go,
oh,
you learn from that shit.
Like you learn not to do comedy in a fucking sports bar when a game on,
you know.
But there's been other ones where they used to do,
there was one that Boston comedies to book for a little while.
That was a disco.
It was like a nightclub and they would stop.
The music's we,
and they wouldn't even have a stage.
They would turn a spotlight on the dance floor and you would stand,
he would stand there with a bunch of people who are standing and you do stand
up.
I,
that's incredible.
I've done,
I've done rooms where the root that is incredible.
It's addict.
Apollo did it.
He always got to fight with somebody and I think that's when they shut it
doesn't have anthropology.
Well I can handle it but knows how to handle that.
But uh,
yeah,
he's another guy who was like hilarious.
Oh my God,
he's so good.
But uh,
he's a good dude too.
Yeah,
he's a great,
I mean that's the thing I've,
I have found with,
with comedy,
when I first started,
I remember it feeling like,
Oh man,
like this,
everyone in this is like weird and competitive.
But then as you do it for a while and you get past that first stage of like
crazy,
just looking for five minutes here and there.
And he really starts to get to know,
like real professional comedians and people will do it.
There was a like weird bond between people who do stand up and like,
it's,
uh,
I've only had,
I mean,
you know,
I can't say 100% of the time,
I'd say 95% of the time I've met other standup comedians at whatever level.
I've had a pretty easy time to chat with them and get along with them.
Like,
it's once,
once you're past that,
like going on,
I MDB and see what the other guys are doing stage and you've got comfortable and
who you are,
you know?
Yeah.
I don't know.
That's been my experience.
I don't know about that experience too.
It's,
it's,
well I ran into um,
fuck,
I forgot who it was.
Um,
but we were just having these exact same conversation.
God Damn.
And who was it?
I forgot.
Dammit.
I hate when I can't pull up a fucking name,
but,
uh,
we're having this exact same conversation and it seems like when you run into
how many comics are there,
is there even a thousand professional comedians in the country?
So if you're running,
he was like,
right now there's like 10,
I don't know,
that's how I feel.
But,
oh,
it was Mario joiner.
That's why I ran into Mario Joiner who was the host of a MTV half hour comedy
hour.
I ran into him at the airport on the way to Toronto and uh,
we were having the same sort of conversation.
It's like as soon as you see someone as a comic,
you're like,
Hey,
I'm,
I'm barely talked to that guy five times my life.
And he was like an old friend.
Yeah,
that's what I mean.
Like,
cause you kind of especially like,
like I've been on the road this last year,
you know,
and I'm,
I'm not at a stage like I'm headlining,
but I'm not,
I don't have fans.
Like I don't have people come see me.
So if I go to like Zane,
he's in Chicago where I go to lake helium in Philly or,
uh,
was just in Madison places where like,
there's fans of the daily show,
probably more than not.
And they promote it pretty well.
I could sell out a room that holds like one 50 to 200 but if I go down to like
Tampa on a Wednesday night and some of those rooms,
great.
I love all those terms,
like size players and so I love those kinds of rooms,
but they're big clubs and you go on like a Wednesday night like nobody comes.
You know what I mean?
I'm like,
by Saturday there's some people in there,
but like Wednesday night,
you know there's like 50 people in a room that holds 400 you're like,
hey,
you know,
like,
and people that just like hammered,
you know,
pooping on themselves,
whatever.
Like,
so it's like I've,
but when you have those experiences and you meet other people have had those
experiences,
like you have a lot,
you know,
there's just eating,
like I've tried now to eat as healthy as it can,
but when I'm on the road I just don't even try because it's,
you're in like a hotel and fucking Kentucky,
right.
And like I,
this is what I say to people.
You know when you're driving on the highway and sometimes you see a guy walking
on the highway,
I'm like,
that's probably a standup community.
Cause like you stay in hotels don't have a car.
And they're like,
yeah there's an Applebee's across the highway mean.
Yeah,
I guess I got to walk a highway like it's a weird,
it's a weird thing.
So you end up doing this stuff.
Other people do that most adult humans wouldn't do.
So you have these like a lot of things to bond over,
you know?
Well just the job itself being so strange coming up a bunch of shit in your head
and then sang it on stage.
I'm totally in front of a microphone with a spotlight on you.
Very bizarre.
And the psychology behind it,
very few people are going to really like really relate.
Yeah.
But if you run into a comic,
it's like wow.
Yeah,
you fucking played that room too.
So you know Charlie goodnight's on a Saturday night,
you know,
and the country western bar is next door.
I remember that spot.
We went next door once we went to Charlie goodnight's went next door.
And there was a country western bar with a bowl,
a mechanical bull packed to the Gills,
and people were singing songs you've never heard in your life.
And everyone knows the fucking words.
They're all singing along and it's America.
It's not like we're in Pakistan
in a jam.
And Angela,
I'm not from this country,
so I don't understand what the,
you know,
the words,
they,
they are all singing along to songs you've never fucking heard in your life.
Oh really?
I thought you were going to say like the classics,
you know,
like from Alabama,
like,
you know how you sing to sweet home Alabama come,
everybody knows that song.
Right.
It's like that,
but a song that you've never fucking heard.
Real country.
Yeah.
Like,
yeah,
get her done.
It's like a Travis trip,
Travis trick tunes on,
you know,
they go nuts.
Yeah.
That's,
it's a whole different part of the world.
Yeah,
it is.
You ever,
uh,
gone to a place and they started talking to you about Nascar?
Yeah,
I've got to,
I've got to places where they don't like me a lot.
Just cause like,
um,
I,
I always feel like the whole thing was stand up when people say like,
well there's a weird thing you have to get over in the beginning,
which is you're kind of an asshole for wanting to do it.
Right.
Cause you're basically saying that people not only do I think I'm funny,
I think I'm so funny that you should sit here not talk,
pay money and hear what I have to say.
So like I always feel like if people don't know you and you don't already have
their trust as a performer,
they just see some guy coming in the room going,
oh here comes some guy that thinks he's funny.
You know?
And like I,
I've found that I ended up in conversations with people in places I don't want
to,
you know,
talk to them,
uh,
or about things I don't want to talk to about.
And I,
in a weird way,
I really like it.
Like I really liked going to places in America that I probably wouldn't have
traveled to.
And like talking to like people who are not from the universe I'm in and
hearing their perspective on Shit.
Like it's kind of interesting.
It's very interesting.
Yeah.
It's very interesting to talk to people that are just as confident in their
beliefs,
which are polar opposite of yours.
And some of them like,
you know,
you'll go to some places in the deep south especially that just assume that you
are,
you're on their side about certain things.
So we'll just start chiming in about yeah,
whatever,
you know,
fill in the blank,
but well this fucking welfare state or you know,
I also feel that sometimes though there is that perception and then there's also
the flip side,
which is not everybody is that not everybody is the stereotype of what you think
those places are supposed to be.
That's true.
You end up getting into conversation with people.
You're like,
yeah,
I don't know.
Like maybe my view on,
uh,
again,
like I said,
we've talked about four guns.
Like,
yeah,
I,
I totally understand the second amendment.
I'm pro second amendment at the same time.
I do think we can,
you know,
tone it down some alley.
We just modify it like we should with some other stuff.
But a man do you get in a conversation like that with people and you find a lot
of people go,
no,
I actually agree with you man.
Like I love guns and I hunt and I this and that,
but like,
you know,
I don't know that it should be that easy to get them.
You know what I'm saying?
Like you get like there's,
there's,
I find that most people are actually pretty reasonable,
you know,
and that they like extreme extreme.
People are not,
are not the majority,
at least my experience.
They're not the majority.
There's a small percentage,
but they're so vocal and so obsessed with angry.
Yeah.
That's with everything.
I know.
Everything,
you know,
you ever go to a men's rights page,
a read a men's rights forum.
Holy Fuck.
Yeah.
That's another one where you going?
Huh?
You know,
it's a tough,
that's a tough train to jump on men's rights.
I mean,
look,
I don't think that guy should get fucked over and divorces,
which seems to be the only issue.
You only issue to me seems to be like child custody and financial support.
That's it.
Those are the only that I don't see any other issues.
I think where else are men getting,
I mean,
maybe there's something else,
but maybe I'm missing it,
but I don't know.
I think it depends on the divorce.
Like I think that,
um,
that depending on what went on in that relationship is really the determining
factor.
I mean,
I guess it's more common for the women to get the kids and more money,
but I think if you're getting kids like then yet you should get the fucking
money.
Like it's the guy's responsibility to take care of these kids even if they get
divorced,
you know,
unless she did something to like,
in danger the family or,
you know what I mean?
Like,
I think a lot of times divorces are,
you know,
one more,
one sided,
you know,
maybe then we realize,
um,
why iPhone is,
I think a lot of times guys are the Dick,
you know,
pretty well.
Sometimes women are evil though,
man.
I've had friends that had been involved with evil divorces.
I've had several friends that lost a shit load of mind.
It just got just GAM.
Yeah.
They got scammed.
I,
I can bring you a bunch of stores,
which I,
I just don't want to talk about them on the air,
but about good friends fucking lost everything they worked for for like a
decade.
Yeah.
Jobbed I know that it happens on both sides.
We'll build it and men get fucked
over.
Feel bird does that fit on a,
and his last special thing was his last one.
The uh,
um,
you people are all the same where he's talking about we have a gold digging like
whore.
It's country.
It's like,
it's unbelievable.
He's like,
that's an epidemic.
Like nobody taught Arnold Schwarzenegger.
How would I handle that level of life?
You know,
he just goes through which words in egg or accomplished to get to where he is
and he's like,
he just makes them a sympathetic character.
It's incredible.
Yeah.
And he's like this guy,
we have a gold digging whores.
He,
so he was calling Schwarzenegger's made Golder.
Yeah,
he was.
Yeah.
He was just,
he was just,
I think,
I think he's calling Schwarzenegger's made a goal.
I'm again,
I want to see it.
I want it.
You got to see him.
But that specialist,
that specialist,
one of the best hours I've ever seen.
I love bill.
Yeah,
he's incredible.
He's funny as shit.
He's incredible.
He always has some great points.
He has this great bit that I was listening to the other day about women saying
that being a mom is the hardest job in the world.
I don't think you do the hardest job in your world and your fucking pajamas.
Oh No,
it's so funny cause I thought it would be being a red head roofing in August.
Okay.
Did he talks about,
he talks about goods in that and that special,
uh,
did he say how he wanted to buy a gun and the guy wanted a shotgun?
You know,
like the guy was trying to sell him on a shot and they got us a guy who's got a
good spray,
it's got to get sprayed.
He goes,
he goes,
look,
I just want to hit the bad guy.
I don't want to be doing all sorts of dry wall work.
He's like,
I don't know what I,
he goes,
I don't want to have to reframe my diplomas and get a new parakeet,
you know,
I just want to hit the bad guy.
Okay.
Fucking,
I wasn't rewatch that 50 fucking tosh my diplomas.
But that's special.
That hour is just like,
he talked and he,
there were moments in that special live on stage and this huge theater where
he's talking about like hitting women things that like,
you just would be so scared to talk about it and he feels the room back away and
he goes,
don't pull away.
He's like,
don't back away.
Like he like goes at them.
It's,
I dunno,
it's just the guys,
this is good.
Like it's the epitome of Boston comedy at the Boston style of attack,
common attack comedy and like owning your perspective,
owning your shit.
You thought it through.
You're going to fight your fights.
It's so good.
Yeah.
He has this
bit too about black people,
uh,
being uh,
they,
they get called racist less than white people just because of where they put the
word fuck.
He goes because a black I would go.
So yeah,
there was this Asian motherfucker and he and,
and you know nobody,
nobody hits a beat.
But if you go,
yeah.
Oh,
fucking Asian.
Yeah.
He goes,
I said the same thing.
I'm racist.
Well,
yeah,
because I put the fuck in the wrong part.
In the wrong spot.
It really funny.
That's very funny.
It's so true.
Yup.
Cause if you will like this Asian fucker and be like,
that's like a cool guy.
Like an Asian fucker,
be a cool guy.
It's fucking Asian.
He was like screwing you over somewhere.
Yeah.
It's a car.
It doesn't like Asians.
One fucking Asian.
Yeah.
That's who bought the new house.
Fucking Asian,
Asian motherfucker.
Oh cool.
All over.
And asked him for that mother fucker.
Totally different.
That's really funny.
Yeah.
Well this is a good time for comedy isn't it?
It's like,
it's a good time to like see different comics.
So many funny comics.
I agree too.
I also think it's cool.
Um,
you know,
I think that the Internet is a cool way to like,
it's get it,
be exposed to people,
you know,
and like,
and,
and see different styles and,
and uh,
different.
I,
I'm always so happy.
Like I,
like I said,
I go,
what are these clubs?
And like,
you know,
they'll pair you up with a middle act or features or whatever,
the same thing,
but over an opener and a like,
there are a lot of guys out there,
there's just good,
they're just really good.
They got like interesting perspectives.
It,
it's funny people and like,
you know,
there's a couple of comics in Austin.
I've worked with it.
I'm like fucking hysterical man.
And there are local dudes and they're like,
yeah,
they haven't jumped on the plane yet to La.
You know what I mean?
Or New York,
wherever they want to do it next.
But you know that that's the really cool thing about comedy is like,
I mean I was from New York and working at the daily show,
so I didn't do anything but try to get up there,
which is always hard,
still is hard.
But uh,
I did a,
but you know,
there's these guys who live in these cities and like there's a whole scene,
a whole comedy scene and it gets tons of stage time.
So they get really,
really good.
They go to these smaller markets like Atlanta,
I did a place called the laughing skull and Lana,
Lana,
like 80 people get some PR and they have like unlimited stage time.
They're like,
yeah,
just whatever man.
Have Fun.
You're like,
okay,
yeah,
I will have fun.
And not,
that's not like 45 minutes.
Come on.
We've got to flip the tables.
It's just like,
yeah,
enjoy yourself.
That's what we do here at the laughing skull and like all the comments are,
they're,
they're cool,
they're good,
they're funny.
It's like,
oh,
there's a whole way to get good at this without having to,
you know,
beg people to give you 10 minutes,
which is,
which is nice.
Yeah.
Well it should,
there should be a bunch of different options,
but it's cool when a club,
like the laughing skull comes along.
We have like one club,
which is sort of the epicenter of creativity.
Yeah.
And all.
I did not make it a lot of money there and they can't be there.
They're having good comics.
I'm sure they're paying the bills and stuff,
but it's not motivated by that.
Well there's a real feeling to that place.
Yeah,
it's the,
it's the restaurant bar that's attached to it.
That's I think making the money,
which is killer too by the way.
The best fucking cheeseburger.
Every can real.
It's a real like southern grease pit.
It's so good.
I actually did a couple,
like after each show I'd like to have a to go whatever gross thing I ordered and
let you know.
That's like another thing you always a combined with comics about is like the
gross thing you ate in your hotel room.
Like just waking up like,
you know,
like going out and do it.
A gig in Philly,
going home,
stop and getting a cheese steak.
Get to go and go into a room just like leaning over the desk in a Hyatt,
like devour your cheese.
They could,
they're getting right into bed.
Just terrible decision making.
You know,
I've done that many times.
I was going to wear my greasy tee shirt today.
I found that I was cleaning out my closet.
I was,
I threw out a bunch of shirts,
you know,
like old stupid MMA tee shirts that people would give me.
I just had stacks of shit that I've been thrown away.
And this a greasy Tony Shirt.
Yeah,
no charge for extra grease.
These used to be this place Greasy Tony's,
which is across the street from the Tempe Improv and it was the quintessential
late night.
Take it back to your hotel room,
eat it.
You wake up,
your room would smell like peppers.
What was it called?
The garbage pail that Garvey had.
That was his big one.
He had a big sandwich called the garbage pail and it was,
everything was in it.
Peppers and tomatoes and lettuce and steak and oh my God,
it was ridiculous.
And you just see the grease stains on like the Hilton blotter on the desk from
the guy before you.
He died of a heart attack.
Oh,
shocker.
Who saw that comment?
Shocking news flash.
He was a great guy.
Unhealthy guy who cooks the things called garbage.
Sad.
We're just had tides of heart attack.
Well we saw him after like a bunch of years.
You know,
we,
we seem there every year and one year he wasn't there and then we saw him the
next year.
Apparently it had a heart attack and then had heart surgery and he lost a ton of
weight.
And you could tell like the end was nigh.
Yeah.
Well once they cut you open and then the next time we came back he was dead.
Yeah,
he was nice.
But it was one of those spots.
Tempe Improv.
You ever do that place?
Yeah,
it's great.
Great,
great,
great club to wild town.
Those people fucking party.
There's a,
there was a few places that every time we're in that city where always like we
got to go to like be buzz or it was that called the a and Houston across the
street.
They had that cheese melted.
She,
I think was Biba have that she,
I'm
fucking forget her name and then it went under two didn't have please go under
or it got flooded.
Well that clock went under so no one goes down there anymore anyway.
You know,
it's just,
that was a perfect example.
Like Houston was an incredible place for comedy,
but it was all because of the last stop,
the last stop in river oaks.
Oh my God.
What a club.
Really,
what a club.
It was fantastic.
I recorded my first CD there in 1999.
That's sick.
Just went under the guy who was running it was this crazy dude who a lot of
people implicated with,
uh,
getting like people were mad at him.
He got drugs allegedly for some comedians and could have included Hedberg
allegedly.
Gotcha.
Yeah.
So he like,
well,
he was running the club,
but apparently it was siphoning money.
Allegedly.
It was you saying allegedly,
allegedly,
these are strange times people should know.
I know it's true.
I'm not even saying his name,
but either way,
that guy for all his faults was the reason why comedy was so like big and that
he like completely supported open mikes.
Completely supported like young talent,
completely supported local talent.
We had a good open mind when it came to comedy.
Really wanted to do the right thing.
It just wasn't really his club.
He was like working for it and you know he kind of,
he led everybody to believe that it was his club.
Gotcha.
There was really an actual owner behind it and then he probably,
the books were cooked allegedly,
but man,
when we were working there,
it was amazing.
It was the perfect setup.
The stage was perfect,
the audience was perfect.
It was one of the proudest places that I like.
God,
I can't even at the last stop,
to me it was like we're Kennison started out,
hick started.
Well I've had,
I find that a lot of the times I've had,
not a lot of the times,
but there's been a few times where I've gone to clubs that are new.
There was one in New York that opened a couple of years ago that I loved called
comics and a lot of comics didn't like it cause it was like look too glitzy and
nice.
But I used to do a lot of sets there and it was with you pack the place as a
really great room and uh,
but they treated you like almost too well,
you know,
like it was like,
well no,
there's like,
there was like a green room and then they will like give you,
there would be like a menu.
They were like,
oh,
what do anything you want?
And it was like,
this place can't sustain.
Like there's no way you can feed comics like that and keep this place going.
There's no way.
It's New York City.
Like the rent must have been 50 grand a week in a month,
whatever.
So,
uh,
all of a sudden over time,
and again I love this club,
but we'd be sitting in the green room and then you know,
that used to be menus and like Fiji water and things like holy shit like this,
like a Tuesday night show worked doing for like 50 people.
What if that,
and there's fucking unlimited and then all of a sudden near the end,
all of a sudden you'd go in the green room and the menu was just like sliders.
There was like one thing out of the venue now and then it was like a thing of
water,
a pitcher of water,
you know what I mean?
And then like he started getting,
like,
they started to just scale back on all that stuff and that's when you were like,
this place is,
this place isn't,
this is going down.
And then all of a sudden they were doing things were after comedy that we're
having djs come in for like late night dance parties.
And I'm like,
yeah,
Shit.
Because like,
was that the one that was connected to the hotel where you can just go up?
No,
no,
no.
That was the one that was in an area that's not known for live entertainment.
14th it's,
it's right by like in the meatpacking 14th and ninth,
there was a,
it used to be a bar called,
uh,
shit.
What was it called?
It was an old,
um,
it was like a throwback,
a saloon kind of bar that they used to have in New York.
I can't think of the name of it was kind of famous and they had peanut shells on
the floor and like,
it was like a coyote ugly type of place.
And I once went there,
I went with her one time I was in college and,
uh,
I saw a guy in a wheelchair get into a fight with a guy not in a wheelchair and,
and he won.
It was one of the more amazing things I've ever seen him like.
Yeah.
Like,
like a bar fight,
except one of the dudes within a wheelchair and he launched himself out of the
wheelchair,
tackle this guy and was just pummeling this dude.
Oh my God,
that was it.
Yeah,
it was,
I was just,
you know,
it was one of those bar fights and all that happened so quick.
You just sort of go in there.
It's that dude did,
that guy just jumped out of a wheelchair,
you know,
and then they,
it got broken up and he just kinda like crawled back to his wheelchair,
barely even crawl.
He like just like forehand things in a spring and he was back in his chair.
It was like,
wow,
that dude's fucking guy's for real.
You know?
That's when I pitched my wheelchair fighting show,
which did,
which never went well.
You ever seen those wheelchair basketball guys?
Yeah.
That was one of the fuckers can move.
Well there's a serious fucking athletes yet,
but that was a really weird bar like for New York City that was not like,
that was before.
Everything kind of turned
in that area.
Like it was a really like shady,
the kind of place where like dude's gotten fights with guys in wheelchairs,
you know,
like yeah,
those areas that you used to be shady and aren't shady anymore.
That's amazing to me how that happened.
Buying up real estate or uncomfortable.
Absolutely.
The New York city's become completely offensively on affordable.
Yeah.
I looked at some places when I was there last like,
like what if I lived here?
What could I afford?
And it was like,
what would that cause what?
It's an apartment.
I mean,
is that a month?
What are you fucking kidding me?
The standard used to be if you were going to buy a place like maybe eight,
nine years ago,
10 years ago,
it would be like $1,000 a square foot to a thousand square feet was a million
bucks and that's like without a view or whatever right now those prices are even
higher.
I think from listings I've seen and now in queens,
like neighborhoods that you,
I don't care like,
like I've like I'm Sam,
I'm from long island queens as part of long island right there.
It's like 10 minutes probably from where I grew up.
Um,
but now you're starting to see these neighborhoods are saying are flipping and
queens are like long island cities.
The coolest,
you've got to get a place there.
Now those apartments are 1000 bucks a square foot and they're outside the
fucking midtown tunnel.
And I'm like,
listen,
I,
I don't care who you're selling on fucking queens.
It's Queens.
Like it's going to be queens.
It's not going to not be queens.
Like don't buy a place there for $1 million.
But what about Brooklyn?
Brooklyn,
Brooklyn used to be Brooklyn.
Brooklyn is same thing.
Yeah.
Brooklyn completely turned.
Yeah,
I mean it's really turned around.
I mean it's like I'm a horrible real estate guy clearly.
Cause even in Brooklyn,
like Yeah,
look at these idiots in Williamsburg,
you know,
I don't know what they're doing.
But yeah,
my friend had a place in Brooklyn that was almost better than living in
Manhattan.
Brooklyn is awesome.
Well he had a place where he was across the river,
but he had this like top floor of this apartment.
We would look out and you see the most insane city cause you saw the city and
the water from a distance.
I was like,
dude,
you might have the best view in the world.
That's this is,
it might be worth living in Brooklyn just for this view.
Well that's what they're selling in queens cause you're right on the other side
of the river.
So you're looking right at midtown God views in sense.
Amazing.
It's almost better than being in it because when you're in it you're like butted
up with all these other buildings.
Absolutely.
Shane's got a spot.
Shane Smith got a spot like on the river.
Yeah.
That's like look out from his,
his living room.
It's just all glass,
you know,
that's that far.
But places like that,
if you've got them,
I don't know him or when he got his place,
but it's like the,
that kind of real estate was like a home run 15 years ago.
You know what I mean?
But now it's,
it's all been discovered.
Like this city is completely,
it's just,
it's,
it's unaffordable to be quite honest.
Thing is like if you look at it from Jersey,
it doesn't look as good.
Like you really want to be in like Bro,
you want to be,
we're like right there on it.
Like if you ever seen the views of like Updo Heeney in the Hollywood hills.
Yes.
Nighttime.
You can't believe how cool it looks.
It looks like you're in a science fiction movie.
No,
it's crazy because you're on,
you're on a hill looking down at the light grid of La and it's magical.
It's almost cooler than the stars.
It really is.
It's like,
it's actually,
it looks a lot like the star.
You're above them and it looks like,
so yeah,
it's very cool.
It's the best view
in all of La.
Like la has some great views.
The views of the ocean is pretty bad ass.
The views of the mountains are pretty bad ass.
But the view over like Doh Heaney looking down like those,
any of those really high spots.
Hollywood hills sponsor foster,
those are scary places though,
man.
Those Hollywood hills,
uh,
houses get robbed.
Yeah.
That's where like the uh,
men,
girls gone wild.
Whatever his name is.
Yeah.
That Guy Joe something or another,
he got,
he kept fucking ass or something like that.
They might've been personal.
Somebody might've done something to him up there,
but people like ice t got home invaded up there.
Yeah.
I know a dude who was in the middle of the nights when we tried to break into
his house.
Shit.
Yeah,
that's scariest guy.
I know it got got murdered up there.
What?
Keanu Reeves the other day had two people break into his house in the same day
and one of them was naked.
Yeah,
but doesn't,
he doesn't eat.
Know Jujitsu.
I note your chin.
That's a victory on his part.
Um,
that's uh,
that's,
I did not know that.
I don't know that much about the,
uh,
the La area.
I just,
I started living here.
I got a place out here and I was digging it,
man.
I was really into it.
Now I'm going back to do with this other thing in New York for a while.
So,
um,
I like it out here a lot.
I really did.
The nice thing is the weather.
The weather's awesome.
Yeah.
But I don't know.
I also just the lifestyle,
there is a difference.
Like when I first got here a couple months ago or a year ago,
I was thinking like,
Oh man,
people out here deck don't work.
What the fuck?
You know in New York people at work and like,
oh well look,
I was saying how expensive it is.
Like you got to work 11 hours just to keep the lights on now.
Right,
but then you realize here,
not that it's,
it's,
it's definitely cheaper real estate wise,
but it's also the style of living is not,
there's like more people like have lunch and like ride their bikes and like
exercise.
It's like there's,
I don't have more free time.
Then you start realizing,
oh that's a whole other way to live.
I kind of like this way to live.
You know?
You don't have to just be like turning the work machine.
It feels like people work at a TV show,
they go on hiatus,
they float for a couple months and they pick up another gig.
They're not like I,
at least that was been my perception.
It's also,
like you said,
also the,
the amount of money that you need to spend to live in New York,
you kind of have,
yeah,
I don't know.
It's like the culture there.
It's like people don't ever,
and a half the jobs,
not even half.
Like it feels like a majority of the jobs in New York are just jobs where you
like sell money to make money.
Like,
cause all these like Wall Street guys.
So there's not even like,
they're not even like an industry don't even like contributing.
They're not even,
he's not anything like this.
Not like shoes that coming off an assembly line.
They're just like,
here's some paper,
here's my paper.
Like,
here's my money.
And then they'll like,
Jetski whoo.
It's like,
it's like this unstoppable like wealth machine.
It's,
it's kind of gross,
you know?
And it's already,
they've become accustomed to it.
Nobody wants to abandon it.
No.
Like they love it.
Yeah.
And it's like some of the hedge fund thing,
it's super,
well,
yeah.
Turks had this thing that they were doing about,
um,
the,
uh,
the presidential campaigns and they have some thing on their linked on their
website where you can,
uh,
for,
you could write in people who you'd like to see run for president instead of,
you know,
Hillary Clinton or whatever.
And they were talking about how much money Hillary Clinton has gotten from banks
just recently from Goldman Sachs,
like doing speaking engagements like hundreds of thousands of dollars just
recently.
Just to give these sympathetic speeches about how people don't understand the
banks aren't that bad and this is all the
whatever,
whatever it takes and you know,
you're not going to stand on your principles when you're looking at raising
money.
Just they're making too much money.
They're fucking use it.
Exactly what you said.
Using numbers,
moving ones and Zeros and taking big percentages of those movements and no one
understands how or
why only do people don't understand it but like it really makes you feel like
the economy is all make believe anyway.
Right.
Cause it's like this weird thing where like you look at your computer screen and
there's like numbers on it and then when you buy something like those numbers go
down,
she don't want the bed.
You have the thing like there's no like there's like sometimes when my credit
card like a hand to somebody by credit card and then they like give me said
item,
I'm like I just get to leave with this now.
Yeah,
I've never really given you anything.
You realize that you just swiped a thing and like there's like sign this thing
and just like a weird,
there's like this weird lack of actual exchange that's occurring,
you know?
And so these guys if like figured out that
them somehow and well they have but they have only because of the need for a
third party system and that's where bitcoin and things like that get very
interesting and terrifying for people that run things right now financially
because of digital currency gets adopted and it is adopted in a lot of ways now.
Like there's a lot of things you can buy and pay for it.
Bitcoin.
There's a lot of people are doing shows we could pay for their show in bitcoin
there they're buying televisions and tiger direct to selling computers with
bitcoin.
I think Dell's using bitcoin to right.
I think I might be wrong about that,
but that when,
if that catches on,
then this,
this whole business goes away because there's no third party if you want to,
if you sell microphones and I say,
Hey Rory,
I want to buy a microphone.
How many bitcoin is it?
And you tell me how much should I give it to you and we're done.
It's just between you and this is a current,
yeah.
Yeah,
like a private car and not only that,
the IRS doesn't know how to handle it.
They're calling it property.
They're not,
they're not saying it's income.
They'll figure out a way to make money on it though.
Oh yeah.
Without a doubt.
The wool.
They're figured out a way to make more money on marijuana.
Well.
That's the whole,
that to me though,
that's the only really that,
I mean,
I guess now it's becoming legal over the country,
but it feels like,
you know,
if they want to make money,
like just tax we'd and made it legal,
like,
you know,
that's going to get us hundreds of millions.
Yeah,
very quickly.
Like it's just like,
that's it.
Like everybody wants it and then you'll make money and then whatever.
It takes some extra money for it.
At least it's not Italy.
I mean,
people go to jail for weed still.
It's also,
it's insane.
It's fucking up this economy because you're giving people money in a way.
If you make it illegal,
you're giving people what they're going to sell it.
They're just going to,
so you're giving people money and you're,
you're figuring out some sort of a way where they have to Juke the system.
They're not gonna pay taxes on it.
You're not going to get your cut.
In Colorado,
they get 39% like if you buy a joint,
39% goes to taxes and like,
okay,
yeah.
Everybody's like,
who cares?
It's still,
it's still fairly cheap.
It's still a couple bucks for a joint or whatever.
It turns out between the album at this point,
those guys,
you go out for drinks.
How much do you spend?
I mean,
everybody buys a drink is five bucks.
It's not a five bucks.
You buy around for your buddies,
it's $30.
It's this,
it's that you're,
you're,
if the end of the night you're out a few hundred bucks,
if you have a couple of hundred bucks of weed,
you're in a fucking coma for a week.
Oh Shit.
You might not survive the first guy to die from a couple of hundred dollars a
week.
That's why it's like,
that's why it's,
uh,
I think that there's the hesitation.
So I think that there's a lot of like big business concern about what does that
mean?
Well,
you know,
I mean like,
alcohol companies,
tobacco companies,
like all,
all,
all sorts of big bribe politicians kind of industries or word,
but,
uh,
what do you call it?
Uh,
uh,
prescription drug companies.
You know,
people that are like concerned that they won't be controlling this substance
that people can,
you know,
it's a lot easier to grow pot in your back yard than it is to like stomp grapes
and make wine.
I think,
well maybe a doubt.
I don't know.
Well it's also they have a real problem when you're running any sort of a giant
corporation is that your business has to increase every year and it's these
unlimited growth models.
Those are ridiculous.
Cause if you have stockholders,
you have to make the money and the way we're up 5% this quarter.
Right.
Well if you keep going,
you're going to have all the money on the planet.
Right.
How is that possible?
It's so weird.
Yeah,
you're right.
It can't keep going.
If you are open for another hundred years business.
It seems to me that if I do my calculations,
IBM or fucking apple,
you have all the money.
Yeah.
If you keep growing,
you own everything.
Yeah.
At certain point in time,
just like that sounds ridiculous.
Well there's going to be like four companies in the whole world.
It's getting there now anyway.
Especially as they start to like,
yeah,
combined,
they all have to be terrified about any potential loss in revenue.
So potential loss and revenue because of legalization of things.
Even if they came up with a potential loss in revenue,
but we cure Ebola.
There's a lot of companies that would be like,
fuck that.
We're not losing money.
Yeah.
Fuck those Africans.
Hey,
if they want to fucking play with bodies over there,
go at it.
I think that that's a very accurate,
uh,
from my understanding of it,
which is limited.
I won't pretend it's not,
but it's like from my understanding of it,
it seems that the,
the,
the straight up hardcore business mentality is the only thing that matters is
is it,
the bottom line is how much we made and,
and that's the job that they have is to just make sure those numbers get high
and then then it becomes this sort of thing.
Well,
who's to tell them what they should or shouldn't do with that money and that's
the larger argument and go,
well,
you know,
governments taking tax on any of that money.
So technically they're given a lot of it away,
you know,
that's nothing anyway.
So then why do we,
they have to kill her bowl it,
why can't they just get a crystal bathtub?
Like what's the fucking who's to say they can't?
Right.
And that's where you get into this,
like what I call like the soup of America right now,
where it's like people are mad that there's like these super rich people.
But then there's another group,
people who were poor and being told that someday they will be super rich.
So they should protect the superpowers.
Right.
And then there's the left who just feels like,
oh no,
no,
everybody's got to,
everyone should have an equal
share of everything.
And I don't know,
you know,
have an equal share.
Well,
some people don't do equal work and that's,
that's the opinion of the right.
You know?
And I agree with that opinion.
Yeah.
I don't think everybody does equal work and deserves equal pay.
But at the same time,
like there is a sector of the population that has not had an equal opportunity
to succeed and that those,
but that's a reality like that those people have not had an opportunity.
That's the big point.
Right.
That's the number one thing.
So I think that was,
yeah cause so it's like you can't compare my childhood to some kid from the
inner city.
You can compare some kid from the inner city to Africa.
No,
no.
These people that have grown up in these mud huts in Africa where you know the,
the fucking,
the bowl will lady who died in the hut next door and the husband's trying to
pretend she's not dead right.
And the whole city gets sick.
I mean that guy's got a way fucking worse than anybody in America ever for sure.
But I mean talking strictly because once you start getting into international
problems,
like really gets fucked up.
Cause he was really format.
There's,
somebody just told me this the other day,
I forget who it was,
the real 1%,
the real 1%.
We talk about the 1% of the people that make the most wealth in this world.
If you make $35,000 a year,
you're in the upper 1% for the planet 30 for the planet.
For the plant.
Okay.
$35,000 a year.
If you make $35,000 a year,
you're in the upper 1% for the planet.
Wrap.
Wrap your fucking head around that.
That's a true no,
I mean,
I don't know.
I'm just not competing it.
Fuck it.
I'll Google it.
No,
but I do think that's true.
I think that like it,
you know,
when you stuck strictly speaking domestically,
cause if you start going to internationally it gets really complicated because
even with global warming,
people talking about like changing,
you know how we live on the planet,
but it's like we know that's not just America,
but you'd really technically have to get the entire world in on that shit.
I don't know if you've seen what's pumping out of the sky in China,
but it's not a scary.
It ain't,
it ain't pretty.
You know,
so even if we turn our shit around,
like,
you know,
the world is,
see that volcano Joe and add Japan.
Yeah.
Dude,
I you,
it's so funny you said that cause I was on this,
uh,
this run last night of researching super volcanoes.
Really?
Yeah.
I'm a fucking idiot man.
What was the point?
You're just scared of interruption.
I,
well I went into a yellow stone and uh,
uh,
was reading about Yellowstone and uh,
about how often it's blown and how many people have died.
And then I found out this one actually in California,
there's one in California,
there's one in,
uh,
like northern California.
There is a Caldera volcano.
Really?
Yeah.
That it hasn't blown and you know,
x amount of 100,000 years.
But there's one in California and then there's the Yellowstone.
Oh,
you mean old man steam pipe.
Well,
there's an even bigger one in Indonesia that they think might have been
responsible for.
The reason why all human beings come from like a group of original humans.
They think that the one that happened in Indonesia was so fucking big 75 million
years ago or whatever it was killed,
or 75,000 years ago did it killed so many fucking people that there was like
very few people left and that we all came from the survivors of this extreme
cold front that washed over the entire country or the entire world and put the
world into essentially an ice age.
She,
yeah,
and the nothing,
nothing anybody could do about that.
It doesn't matter how much plastic is in the ocean.
Doesn't matter how much you clean up the streets then which matter how much you
stop the gentrification of Brooklyn and fucking give back to the core.
If that motherfucker blows,
that's a wrap.
Yeah.
That mother fucker blows.
There's not much anybody can do,
but try to figure out a way to can food and preserve,
you know as much nutrients as you can and bags and get underground and you'll
probably bred,
brings some fucking vitamin D because you're not going to get any yeah.
From the sun for the next decade.
Let's be realistic.
Bring a high end vitamin D,
the video of
tourists with all the ashes just coming right towards towards them.
And they were still finding bodies in his ass.
It was,
I guess need deep Jesus Christ.
Oh my God.
That's so scary.
That's really scary.
That's a scary that they can't predict that shit too.
It's just sort of blows man.
Just boom.
Yeah.
Well they can't really.
Yup.
It's $34,000 globally.
$34,000 a year.
You're in the top 1%.
That's crazy.
That's absolutely crazy.
That's what's really going on in the world.
That's,
that's,
that's what should scare the fucking shit out of everybody.
Yeah.
No,
it is.
That's real disparity
is real disparity.
And we do take,
we take most of what we have,
I think for granted.
I mean,
uh,
you know,
it's like you ever,
like I was when I flew in here,
you know,
it's like they,
they got on the PA on the planet.
Oh,
you know,
the Wifi is down on the planet here.
People really,
CK has a whole bit about that.
Well.
Oh wait,
the one about exactly.
Is that the one about what you fly like a God?
No,
no,
no.
He's like,
everything is awesome and nobody's happy.
Oh right.
Yeah.
That bit shutting down on the plane.
That's exactly.
Really.
Yeah.
I know I have not piece of shit doesn't work.
It's like it goes to space.
The is that this in that same bit where he says and then what?
You fly like a Greek myth.
Oh yeah.
Okay.
That's hilarious.
I didn't know he talked about Wifi and plans cause I thought that was,
I wasn't even,
again,
not even trying to do a bit.
Um,
so good.
Again,
perfect example.
What we're talking about,
not trying to a bit,
but just the idea of like we do take and Louie I think is on the forefront of
bringing all that shit up.
Like he's,
that's why he's so fucking awesome.
It's just like we're always unhappy and we take everything for granted and there
that I could,
the thing that opened my eyes in that more than anything was when I did a Uso
standup tour last summer and Afghanistan and hung out with those fucking guys
and was like,
not only am I a huge pussy,
which was had been confirmed years ago,
but I have no,
I have no bed.
Like right to even fucking bitch about the kind of shit that I can think of to
complain about.
No,
right.
Zero zero.
Right.
And I,
and I and I really have made effort,
concerted effort
to like not let that kind of shit bother me anymore.
Even when people talk about habits
like dude to fucking touch screen computer in your pocket like 10 whenever,
10 years ago you couldn't even imagine the shit you could do on this,
you know,
fucking like,
ah,
but it's amazing if he's got a fucking signal and I don't,
I'm pissed.
I'm sure what you said.
Yeah.
Well the other thing is downloaded and shit and I can't even check my email.
The reverse part of the argument is,
but I'm also spending like 200 bucks a month for it.
So like you better fucking work.
Right.
That's the other part of the argument.
You know,
how much should it be worth?
What's the realistic number of what?
How much should a phone would be worth?
It should be worth like $1 million.
I mean,
this fucking phone,
right?
How much can I do for you?
But that's when you think about what a phone actually done built by slaves.
Joe,
don't the trick.
Yeah.
You know that's again though you it and the hypocrisy of all things.
Or you can't ever escape being unintentionally being a hypocrite,
not even unintentionally.
Let's just put willfully ignorant at the top of the list of anybody that's like
super progressive.
I'm only a Vegan.
I'm only trying to save the whales.
I only,
I,
I don't want to harm anything,
but I have a fucking iPhone,
like the human rights.
It's a little bottle of conflict minerals and your hand do that shit came out of
an African boy,
Doug.
That shit out of a hole in the ground with a stick.
That's probably the origin of the minerals and the cold tran inside your phone
and then like a suicidal worker in a Chinese factory put this thing together on
like two hours of sleep and like a 30 hour work day.
Yeah,
with a place that has nets all around that build so that when they jet,
when they do or if they jumped,
they might not die.
This conversation with some pretty fucked,
it's actually very fucked up and we just deal with it because whatever,
man,
what am I going to do?
Not have a phone.
You know?
We accepted there was a company for a while that was trying to do a Fairphone.
You remember that?
Go Google that Fairphone see if that,
whenever it happened with that,
there was,
they were like,
they were only gonna do like three g and people like what?
We were about four g LTE.
Fuck this.
Fairphone everybody just abandon them.
But the idea with boys,
we got to be no conflict minerals.
They were going to do it,
then we're going to,
it was going to be ethical.
It's going to cost a little bit more.
Oh,
Fairphone there.
But a conversation with a friend and he was like,
well,
did you know that the people that jump off the building and China,
it's actually the same percentage commit suicide,
those factories as the national average.
I go,
yeah,
but how many of the national average killed themselves while they're at work?
And he's like,
yeah,
but then they worked there and they live there too.
I'm like,
yeah,
see that's the problem,
right?
In other words,
you can't,
oh,
well,
if it's the national average,
it's still seems like if the guy who made my phone wanting to kill himself,
it's still a little bit,
it should be a little bit of guilt in every haunted device.
Every fucking call,
you know?
Yeah.
That's fucking devices haunted,
right?
Yeah.
How it rings.
It should make you feel a little sad,
but I need it.
I ordered a six.
I haven't gotten
the Fairphone is now in stock.
What's the specs?
Brian?
Read the specs right here.
It says front camera one,
three mega bites.
Android gigabytes and gigabytes.
Pixels rather.
Yeah.
Gigabytes Nigga pigs.
Mega pixels.
A android o s 4.2 jelly beans.
Smells like Petrouli kick out
the new one and all the crystals inside her spiritual.
They're all like,
yeah,
remove demons from your soul.
Which version of Android is a run?
Is that the latest?
No.
And what the fuck?
I mean it looks literally,
it's like a phone from five years ago,
but what is their pitch like?
What do they guarantee everyone?
Everyone who worked on it was really happy.
Conflict free.
Our soldering pace uses 10 yeah,
it can be a shitty signal when you're on the subway.
Don't get it.
Yeah.
Jesus paste soldering paste with the Yucca plant.
Ground the roots to make a
phone.
GPS,
Wifi and grass fed,
Bluetooth grasp.
Gluten free
campus Hmo.
No HMO,
no GMOs.
It's all fucking with your awesome free.
Makes you a better person when you have it in your pocket.
Totally does.
And it doesn't give you cancer like every other phone.
No.
It actually,
it actually cures cancer.
No,
Sheryl Crow thinks she got cancer from my phone.
I did not know that Cheryl Crow is brain cancer and she attributes it to when
she was yeah,
when she was doing that all up on it too.
Apparently when she was doing press for that album,
like back in the nineties or whatever it was,
she had no,
it was the old school phones.
She did hundreds of calls and she did them all with her cell phone without uh,
without,
uh,
no,
just holding it up to her head.
Her head.
That's what everybody did.
Nobody had a fucking button.
Remember those old phone?
We got STARTAC who's didn't have a thing from microphone.
He didn't have a thing that you put on your ear.
We liked it.
I was happy.
I was this stock.
I used to start tack up hill both ways,
but now everybody has some sort of a headpiece and for the most part usually I
usually use the same ear buds.
Those microphones are good man.
Those little apple ones.
I've tried a bunch of different things,
but it seems like everybody can hear me from those little white apple ones.
The good ones the best.
They seem to be like everybody wants the newest,
but for just being on the phone don't seem to be the best.
Yeah.
I also,
uh,
I also think when you have the Bluetooth earpieces always worried me out cause
it feels like,
well isn't that still a signal?
Like it wasn't that the whole purpose and like you still have something
radiating next year.
Anybody dying from it,
but it would,
if it makes you just a little stupid or,
I dunno.
That's could be,
we're ready.
What's happening?
Well that's,
that's what people worry about.
Wifi signals.
I mean,
I don't know how much time you spend in the real wilderness,
but this going to sound totally unscientific and probably ridiculous,
but I like it.
I have a feeling that there's a little something that your body is interacting
with when you're in a room that has wifi.
When you're in a town that has radio,
there's television signals in the air.
Everywhere you go,
there's cell phone signals,
there's signals in the air and they freak out.
Bees.
The bees have a real hard time with cell phone signal problem.
Yeah.
It's one of the big problems.
Pesticides is another one that's two bats again.
Oh fuck.
That's are getting fucked up too because there's signals all it can't track.
Yeah.
They can't track their signals.
I like end up fucking eavesdropping on your call and hitting the fucking boss or
something.
Yeah.
Maybe if your phone drops off because of bat,
every time you drop a call at bat dies and just think about what,
what's going on in the air.
There's so much stuff in the air and if you are a bat or a B,
it's like they're having a 24 hour fucking party next door.
But you live in this toss.
Some neighborhood you grew up there,
your family's from there.
Everybody else's families from there.
And in this neighborhood,
every time he would open the door,
you just hear a Chirp,
Chirp,
chirp.
You'd see fucking butterflies flying.
And then next door,
this fucking death metal band.
And they rehearsed 24 hours a day.
Or
Zach Efron's fractures in next door.
I didn't see the other.
Um,
but yeah,
no,
and the other part of that too is a,
um,
when you go into like a less populated area that doesn't have all these signals,
do you ever go to lock your car with your little life key fob thing?
And you could do it from like two blocks away when you're not,
but when you're in like a city,
you got to go like that tour because the signal cabinet,
it's always that little time to like,
there's a lot of shit flying around in the air all the time.
But just to think of that signal and what is happening there,
I'm pressing a button and then this little thing flies over and opens up and you
could start your fucking car with it.
And you know they have them for cell phones too,
right?
Where you could start your car from your phone from miles away.
I can do it.
Yeah.
Oh that's so ridiculous.
I can unlock my car.
He's that dude disengagement.
In other words,
I'm going old school and getting a car that you need to use a fucking key
though.
Like a car with a key.
I need a car with a key.
The only problem with the key car is if you're in a parking garage and there's a
murderer coming after you,
you always drop them.
You know what I mean?
You always,
you,
oh,
you can't ever get them in the hole.
My car doesn't have a key hole,
like a key hole.
There's no hole anywhere on my car,
but can't you leave your keys like I,
you know it doesn't take,
I don't think my Porsche has a keyhole and shit.
I don't think it does.
Yeah,
because your car note,
your car knows when your keys are near it,
so it doesn't have,
my BMW doesn't even have a key.
My car got this thing right.
My car has a,
but sensors,
so if it's someone else's,
but it won't start.
I think I'm going to go old school.
I'm just going to try to figure out if I could drive around in 1969 Mustang,
not lose my boss here.
You can.
That's the only problem with those cards of,
I'm sure you have a job in those old mustangs,
is there's not a lot of them.
Don't have power steering.
So when all those old mustangs had power steering
steering,
is that what,
I don't know.
Maybe you could go design.
A buddy of mine in high school had one of those man and like it's they're fun to
drive,
but for an everyday car like you want to go park,
you're like shit.
It's like I'm turning a boat.
But yeah,
I think,
um,
but I think the real issue with those cards is they handle like dog shit.
Like have to figure out someone who can,
they can do what they call a pro pro touring version of those cars.
So they take an old car and then they put like a more modern suspension on it so
you could actually drive it.
But it's still never going to be like the new cars.
Like if you hit your brakes,
there's antilock brakes.
Like people forget about like locking your breaks up.
How Matt like that new,
the newest cars now have sensors on them.
Oh yeah.
If somebody cuts in front,
you would automatically brakes.
There's a lot of those,
especially if you'd like to text and drive.
You know,
they don't even have to fucking look at him.
I rented a car and he'd,
I'm,
it swerves you back.
If you go over the line,
like if you go over the line on the highway,
go boom.
It goes like this.
It pulls you back like that.
It takes some getting used to though,
right?
Well,
you can shut it off if you want to.
Weird freaks out and just like slams on the brake.
You're going like 90 on the freeway at slams on the brakes or jerks over you and
you hit it better yet.
What about that Michael Hastings Guy,
their guy that committed suicide,
who was going after all these generals and expose all this crazy shit and was,
you know,
said to all of his family that he was worried that they were going to try to
take him out and then he winds up going down.
Was it sunset some?
Where was it?
Highland,
some major street in La.
It's going to 120 miles an hour and slammed into a fucking tree car explodes
engine goes flying engine,
flew away from the car like Sharif feet.
Oh it's crazy story.
The conspiracy theorists love this story like no other because if anybody was
ever going to get killed,
it was this motherfucker.
He was going after generals.
But that is,
those are the times we're conspiracies make more sense to me.
Yeah.
You know,
cause those are like closed.
Those are closed networks like [inaudible] I,
my whole problem with conspiracies is like people aren't good at keeping secrets
man.
So when they're,
when they're that big,
I have a hard time,
you know,
it was good at,
I don't think that governments that organized,
but I could see some general is taken out a mother fucker,
you know,
like that makes sense.
Those industrialists dude that run everything,
they're pretty good at keeping secrets.
I mean when you find out about like this,
this new,
the Lehman Sachs' tapes that just came as a Lehman Sachs.
Goldman Sachs.
Yeah.
Goldman Sachs' tapes that just came out.
If you paid any attention to this.
It's the banker.
I don't know what the fuck in revelations for,
but apparently people are freaking out about these new like hours of tapes that
just came out to just show how they've paid off the regulatory commissions.
Like how the whole thing is like the bankers but established the standards and
run the system.
But there's legalities that go on.
Another loophole were politicians meet.
This happens with Nancy Pelosi and everyone kind of just stopped talking about
it.
But it's like they meet with these stock guys,
get all this insider information and then are still allowed to invest in the
companies and fucking make money on it.
I saw unbelievable and how it's,
it's not legal,
but it's only legal cause it's the people who make the laws.
I don't,
and I don't know that,
that those are the issues that really hurt my brain and especially since we get
distracted by something else.
And then we stopped talking about it and then somehow it just is okay.
If this is the Bloomberg,
this is the,
the,
the article saying the reporter,
uh,
Jake Bernstein is obtained 46 hours of tape recordings made secretly by a
Federal Reserve employee of conversations within the Fed and between the Fed and
Goldman Sachs
now calling it the ray rice video for the financial sector.
This is a,
this is scary shit.
They don't need to call it that.
They have,
right.
Stupid.
They have to,
that's a stupid name for it.
It's the next and Lindsay Lilly.
It's the Anthony Wayne pictures of real estate or the best one of that is when
someone talks about a word that's offensive and they'll say it's our nigger like
tranny.
They're the,
they're using that with,
for tranny saying,
that's our nigger.
Yeah.
And that's the,
I'll thing with that too,
is there,
there's got gotta be like a,
an update on the,
on what's offensive.
Well,
you know,
sometimes and then you don't know it.
And then you say,
and the people that go,
oh,
you can't say that.
Like,
I didn't know retards out.
You know that last longer now for a couple of years.
A couple of years.
Yeah.
I don't,
I stopped,
I stopped using retail.
I stopped.
What about a bitch,
you know,
was on its way out.
But yeah,
bitches and so it was pussy pussies hunts where people don't like calling
somebody week using a feminine expression.
But when a girl calls a man a pussy,
I like it.
Fuck yeah.
No,
but I also think it's weird.
I think it'd be weird if you look,
in other words,
the idea of like a bitch or a pussy,
but it's like dude,
you don't be such a pussy.
But if,
yeah,
I guess that's like,
all right,
so that means your making like putting a female Jen,
you know,
making it a gender thing.
It makes that women are weaker but then the same time,
how weird would it sound if you made that the other way?
So like pussy was mean.
You mean you were like a bad ass like nude dude,
you don't have a pussy big enough to jump off that fucking ledge.
Like it doesn't work that way either.
You know what?
I know Buddy Dick Dude,
how bitch you pussy bro.
You can do it.
The water's cold.
Don't you know what you'll tell a girl she's got balls.
Yeah,
yeah,
you're right.
I Dunno.
I guess I see it.
One means brave and when means week,
but at the same time micro managing,
it's only do some of it's like,
I feel like with some of that stuff I feel like,
I don't know man.
I'm cooked like that's fine if the next generation Ha yeah.
Remember your grandparents.
Like there's certain fucking things where like,
I dunno,
like,
I'm not going to say Asian,
like I'm too old.
You know,
like ty,
it's Oriental Oriental.
Look,
we had to change from China meant the Oriental,
I don't want to change another time I was with my friend and fucking diner once
and this guy said something like,
uh,
to my friend,
like your kind of people.
And uh,
I,
and so I saw my friend,
like sitting there going,
I go,
what kind of people?
I asked the question for him and we got to go.
So,
you know,
colors.
And he didn't think there was anything wrong.
Correct.
Because he was like,
you know,
we were probably like 18 and he was his,
that was his.
Yeah.
Well that's still seems weird.
Weird.
Yeah.
It was real weird.
But he was not being disrespected.
Of course not.
I just thought that was the appropriate,
yeah,
but that's the thing that does happen.
Like it is hard for people to keep up with changes in language because you're
just used to,
I don't know,
I grew up was saying retard and the f word we can,
you know,
the problem with retarded is retarded is actually,
if you think about the word,
it's meaning like to slow growth.
Yeah.
If you'd just tell someone that's a retarded way of looking at something,
there's like they're slow growth in the way you look like you,
you're gonna need you to catch the fuck up.
It's a valid way of saying it.
But when you call someone a retard,
right.
Is that implies that they have down syndrome,
down syndrome or,
yeah.
Some kind of a mental handicap.
Do you know that used to be mongoloid.
I like the term that they used to use mongoloid idiot.
Who's the turn they used to use on your birth certificate if you're born with
down syndrome.
Yeah.
Yeah,
I know,
I know there's books.
If you read like a anthropological books from like the 1800 [inaudible] the way
they refer to different kinds of people like oh yeah,
it's frightening.
It's after audience Russell was on the podcast.
He's awesome by the way.
I heard that,
that he said,
yeah,
but did you hear what he was talking about about the Irish?
The Irish guys considered chimpanzees.
They were less or less than blacks.
Yep.
Yeah,
and that they were,
their race was,
that's the other thing that always is so fascinating to me.
You guys were talking about that,
but this idea now that like you get,
and he was talking about it like they became cops in this and like get
assimilated into white culture,
but there's a whole white that anyone who tries to back to Ellis island or this
is,
you know,
I'm like,
I'm an Italian Jew.
Like that's not really like a tent.
Like when people get like,
I know like I have a lot of like a tally and like long island fan know,
like,
who's like,
I'm not fucking Mexicans coming in.
Like that kind of shit.
And like,
it's like that's just,
they're just the Italians have now.
You know what I mean?
Like the Italians were just the Mexicans of like the early 19 hundreds like
nobody liked them.
They were pieces of shit.
They were like laborers,
all this shit.
So it's like,
it's weird to think that your white privilege.
Yeah.
Like it's like,
well,
you know,
you hear Hannity and these guys going out of the way America,
it's be like,
dude,
you're a fucking Irish guy.
Like you're two generations away from just being a piece of shit.
Like don't treat those people like a piece of shit.
Well,
not only that,
you came directly from emigration.
Yeah.
100% and you're like succeeding in this country in the than the way you're a
great grandparents dreamed he would not even dreamed.
You know,
their wildest ways.
Right.
In their,
its ways.
Yeah.
And so it's always astonishing to me when it's like,
oh no man,
anti immigration,
you know,
and I,
and you know the whole idea that of like,
and look again illegal immigrations at different argument,
but there is a,
there is a tendency to like be waiting online at the nightclub and then you get
in and you're like,
look those,
they're going to let those assholes and you look back at the line and you're
like,
dude,
you just got it in the fucking club.
You know what I mean?
Like,
well I think if people could fly around,
it would be even more ridiculous to not have immigration because the people
could fly around if we all have flying cars,
just go across the border left and right and there'd be no one to stop you
because you could just go anywhere you want.
Right.
Unless they figured out a way to grid up the sky where they could block you and
give,
do a traffic stop in the sky above Mexico.
But if they couldn't do that,
how the fuck are you ever going to tell people where they can go or not go?
They're going to go with work is where's the jobs?
The jobs were in America.
They would go to America and then America would overrun and people would start
slowly trickling back into Mexico and reestablishing and it would
even out eventually.
But if they don't do that,
it's almost never going to even out.
It's gonna.
Like people were like,
ah,
Mexico's need to get their shit together on their own.
Part of the reason why their shit is fucked up,
it's because they're connected to the great barbarians of history,
right?
Like they are the border,
they're next door to the greatest war machine,
the planet earth,
and the human race has ever known.
And so they're feeding it cocaine.
Right?
But at the same time,
you know,
but if you look at like Canada,
right?
We don't have like the same issue in the north.
No,
we don't.
There is something to be said about like what the life is like for Mexicans in
Mexico.
You're talking about $35,000 being the 1% like that life in that country and a
lot of ways is like it's not a good life.
Well,
isn't that similar in,
in,
in the way you can analyze it though to like say Compton.
I mean look at that.
Compton is a part of La and so as Beverly Hills and they're all connected to
each other,
they're all right,
but one of them is way the fuck over there and that's considered Compton and
this is this terrible impoverished community and they're right over here.
We have Beverly hills.
Yeah.
And you could get lucky and be born in Beverly Hills to family that lives in a
gated community and takes you to a private school and everything's fucking
smooth sailing.
Or You'd get the shit end of the stick.
And a single mom and Compton who's on welfare gives birth to you in a crime
ridden household and terrible neighborhood filled with gang violence.
Both of those,
I mean the idea of a border protecting you from anything that's happening in
Canada or anything that's happening in Mexico.
If ultimately it seems kind of silly.
Yup.
Nice.
At some point in time it seems crazy that a person has a chance or doesn't have
a chance based on what patch of dirt.
They just got shit out on.
No doubt.
And then that,
I mean that's,
that's a whole,
I mean that's the bottom line is though,
that's just living in modern society.
We have to have some rules.
And I,
my thought is like we do have poor people.
I mean that's what we were talking about,
about people needing help and it's like that's where it gets complicated in
America because it's like you want to help people.
But then he's like,
all right,
well what we want to help people but we don't want to have a system where people
are like fuck it.
I don't need to work.
I'm getting this sweet though.
Cause that's a whole other problem.
It's a huge,
and then it's also like,
well I work really hard and I'm given a lot of my money back to the government
and like I,
I don't really have much of a say in how they manage that money.
And I don't think they do a very good job of it,
which I think anyone would say.
But then at the same time,
somebody,
so now you're going to have that whole argument about people who live here and
are born here and what rights they have by being born here,
even at all.
All it is is like I was literally born here,
but we got to make a rule somewhere.
I think about how radical a proposal would be if a presidential candidate or
someone got on television and had a detailed outlined idea of how they want to
improve inner cities.
And one of them,
it starts with reeducating the,
the adults in the community.
I mean people would be like,
what the fuck?
But if they don't do that,
anything else you do.
If you don't,
if you add money and if you give people money for nothing,
you can call it whatever reparations.
You could call it welfare.
You know,
depending on what race you're talking about,
just giving impoverished people money,
white people included,
people were poor,
lived to fuck up errors.
You give them opportunities to give him money,
give him education.
If you don't do something about the mindset of the adults,
nothing's going to change because there's still going to abuse their kids.
There's still going to have terrible ideas of the world.
It's a big part of these communities is not just a financial strife.
It's also that you're stuck with a bunch of fucking dummies.
Yeah,
but at the same time,
it's a culture that has been an abused culture in this country for a long time.
It's certainly not white folks that are poor too.
If you're in a trailer park in West Virginia,
that's just as bad.
I mean,
you're a,
you ever see the wild and wonderful whites of West Virginia fucking wild ass
documentary?
You've seen that.
I've seen clips of it.
I've never seen the whole thing fucking awesome on my list.
Awesome.
But these people,
I mean,
you might as well be a black in the south,
right?
You might as well be in a poor neighborhood in Compton or watts.
It's you're fucked.
You got born into this Nigga,
me and a bunch of criminals.
That's the problem.
That's not the problem,
but that's the complication with a system that's like where people go,
well look this country,
you know,
pull yourself up by your bootstraps and work your ass off.
But it's like,
hold on a minute.
Like my bootstraps,
we're pretty fucking high.
Yeah.
We're out of the gate.
Like they were barely,
they were already at my knees when I was born,
you know.
And that was,
I wasn't born rich,
but I was born like,
uh,
you know,
I came from Italian Jews,
like working class people,
hardworking people,
but I was able to go to college.
I was able to like do an internship for it.
Get Dave leadman for a summer.
Like yeah,
you can't,
you don't get opportunities like that if you need to fucking have a job and
shit.
Like that expression born on third and thinking he hit a triple.
No,
no,
no.
And I'm saying I think that the P I don't have guilt about it because I think
the people that worked before me worked for,
and I knew my grandfather is very well,
like those guys were like stealing coal off of trucks to keep warm kind of dudes
and they worked their ass off so that everyone could do better.
And now I'm that next generation who's doing,
you know,
been given a lot because of their hard work.
I have appreciated it on all levels,
but definitely easier for me to do comedy as a code range.
But if you could do it,
okay,
you,
you spent all these years working for the daily show and there's a lot of
political thinking,
you know,
involved in that kind of a job.
If you could fix it,
what would you do?
I mean,
if someone said,
all right,
President Rory,
right?
You have all this money to help take all that.
First thing I do is I want a lobster sandwich.
I just start ordering you.
You could get anything you want any time,
right?
I don't think you can.
Nothing sexual.
Oh,
well,
nothing sexual mouth shut.
You mean the guys running the free world?
That's what I'm saying.
Once he gets a robot fucked all,
everyone's going to shut their mouth.
I don't think the president shouldn't be allowed to have the robot fuck doll.
He should love Mrs. Obama.
She's a wonderful woman.
I wouldn't know.
I would be so happy if she was mine.
Yeah,
man.
I don't know man.
I mean,
I wish I,
I wish,
I ha I don't hit.
Is it kind of part of the problem that's a part of the problems that everybody
has this complaint that we need to make the poor rich and or help them out to
make the poor rich sat.
Not even saying that.
I'm just saying everybody has this complaint.
There's this disparity in wealth.
Everybody
has this complaint that the,
the,
you know,
the people that are in the minorities that are,
that are in poor neighborhoods,
crime ridden,
there's,
they don't have a chance and you're right,
but with a fucking be done.
You know,
I don't think there's such a thing as a society of where nobody's poor except
for like,
like Norway or like those weird look Nordic countries where people,
I don't know,
somehow we're all rich and penis society.
It doesn't mean it's not possible.
But there's this.
But I do like George Carlin used to have a thing where he would talk about
poverty when we go like this,
how the world works,
you know,
it's,
there's uh,
there's rich people,
um,
uh,
who do none of the work,
make all the money.
Then there's the middle class who do all of the work,
make a little bit of the money,
and then there was the poor to scare the shit out of the middle class.
So they keep showing up to their jobs every time.
You know what I mean?
And it's like,
it's like the system needs to function in some capacity,
so there's always going to be poor people.
And I do think that,
like,
I,
I do believe that like in a lot of cases,
the richer people in this country,
some of them were born privileged,
but somebody along the way,
it was shrewd,
somebody was smart and a lot of times it was just screwing people over.
I mean,
if you look at all the tight deck,
the tycoons of like the industrial age and all those guys,
they fucked over a lot of people to get really rich,
you know?
And also like,
so I don't know,
a lot of times the people who got here first have all the money,
like the real wealth in this country,
like the waspy wealth.
It's like Plymouth rock.
That's like Folgers.
Like those guys came over on the,
on the boat,
on the Mayflower,
and we're like,
I'll be the coffee guy,
you know?
And like,
that's it.
Like no one named Folgers is worked again,
you know,
so it's like they were just calling shit.
That's the ultimate,
you know,
spoon in your mouth.
That's the ultimate privilege.
And luck is being a part of some oligarch family.
But do you ever see that Jamie Johnson made that movie called born rich a couple
years ago from the,
uh,
he's at the Johnson and Johnson air.
Good.
Yeah,
it's good.
And uh,
it's called born rich.
It's a documentary and it's like,
it's,
he shot it on video.
I mean it's,
but it's very good.
And it's all about the weird struggle that these kids have who are not rich.
Like get a job rich.
Like you don't ever have to do anything ever again.
And they talked,
I think he got sued actually by the,
the Vanderbilt Kit,
not Vanderbilt.
Uh,
Carnegie,
one of the Carnegie kids who he was friends with growing up,
cause he was friends with Vanderbilt Carney and,
and this kid is telling a story about how he was with his grandfather.
Um,
one day walking in front of grand central station and he goes,
this is yours.
And he's like,
what is,
and he's like this station,
Grand Central,
you won't it.
That's at the Carnegie family grants.
That's right.
And in front of Carnegie Hall,
well,
not just cranking all,
but in front of grand central station.
There is a,
oh no,
Vanderbilt is who owns con,
uh,
of grand central station in front of it.
There's a big statue still.
There's big bronze statue of Cornelius Vanderbilt who was his,
who is like his great grandfather and he's like,
he gave New York grand central station.
That's what I'm talking about.
Like rich,
like,
like Rockefeller gave New York the palisade cliffs.
It was like,
you can have these
but you can't build on them.
I like the look of the cliffs like that kind of show people that like most of
New York,
which is like gifted by rich today.
But my name on it.
Yeah,
it's pretty crazy.
So these kids are the areas of,
of those kids with those guys and they're pretty fucked up,
you know,
and like,
and Jamey Johnson's Dad,
you imagine as like running Johnson and Johnson.
You think he's probably going there everyday with a suit and tie on and be like,
we need more cute tips now.
Too Hard,
you know,
like,
no.
He's like sitting in his fucking garage painting.
He's like,
he's never worked a day in his life.
Wow.
It's pretty,
it's like his,
yes.
Be Hard to feel confident.
Well,
that's the whole point in the movie.
It's like they have no direction in life.
They have no sense of purpose.
Now a lot,
most people go,
fuck that.
I'd find a direction in life with a billion other,
but I dunno.
Like there is something about working,
feeling like you have a sense of purpose.
Something about developing your personality.
I mean,
you have to develop your personality through your character gets developed
through adversity,
overcoming adversity,
lessons learned.
If there's no lessons learned is no wisdom.
Yeah.
If you haven't experienced anything difficult or pulled anything off,
you're not going to have confidence.
You're not going to have the confidence that you can do.
You might have some cocaine fueled,
ridiculous confidence so you can get a fucking king of the world,
but it's not.
It's not.
You know,
it's not reality.
Right.
I have a friend who has a friend.
I don't know the guy very well.
I've had conversations with him,
but he was a part of some insanely large family that has billions of dollars.
They own like half of like the,
they have a stretch of buildings in Malibu on the beach where they started
buying up the neighbor's buildings cause they didn't want anyone next to them.
So they would just like the neighbor was selling their house for $24 million to
just snatched it up.
She's just so they could have the neighbor's house to write.
He just owned the houses around the,
they have billions and billions of dollars so,
so they just didn't trust fund burn through it.
Had a backup trust fund burned through that.
How do you,
I don't even know.
He's like in his late forties,
he's a d just as disaster,
degenerate disaster,
just a disaster.
And everyone,
you know,
they would feel,
when of you're going to get your shit together,
sir,
you know,
it's never going to happen.
This fucking guy.
And he was having a conversation with my friend and uh,
he said,
if whatever you do,
because she has kids,
he said,
whatever you do,
do not let your kids have money.
Don't give them any money.
It makes him like,
he was acutely aware of his own failings because he was born to this billion
dollar empire.
Yeah.
Just had no concept of what it meant.
It's just not a man,
like when you're around him,
he's just got no confidence,
no nothing.
He didn't do anything.
Grit.
There's no grit.
Like he's never been a piece of shit to anybody.
And it's not to say that someone who's born in that same scenario couldn't have
found,
you know,
like painting or music or become like successful at something they do on their
own or decided,
you know,
I'm never going to touch that money or I'm going to donate that money to
charity.
I want to,
I recognize the pitfalls of this scenario.
So I want to be something different other than,
you know,
with this map is sort of leading me to go into a certain direction.
It's possible.
You could also,
I mean we were originally talking about how hard it is to be poor.
Now we're talking about how hard it is to be rich.
I mean much more.
I know.
I would also
say that like if you really fucking wanted a man up,
like then fucking go live for a year with you know,
$50,000 in a bank account and go live somewhere in the country and try to serve
it like fucking test yourself.
That's not even real though.
Cause they know they can always go back.
This year is up.
I'm killing Vietnamese.
Sure.
Though I'm sure there are.
Um,
there are rich people who have,
you know,
found a way to fucking sucks,
give back or do something in life besides like feel bad about the fact that they
can just do whatever the fuck that urge Guy Richard Branson.
Yeah.
Famous for that.
But he,
yeah,
if he made all this money itself,
yeah.
Oh you made all your money yourself.
It's a little different.
A lot different.
Yeah.
Richard Branson.
But Richard [inaudible] Streeter Seidel is a really funny comic and writer and
say just got a job at SNL.
But he was,
he did a thing on that show I worked on with Neil Brennan this summer where he's
talking about Richard Branson does his favorite rich guy cause he does all the
things you said you would do if you were a rich guy when you were a kid.
Like I'm on a hot air balloon around the world,
you know like he is like he,
he's like,
I'm going to build this space ship like Richard Branson,
you know,
would you ride that fucking spaceship?
That's like a hundred grand.
I would ride it like 10 years in.
You know like once I know like it blew up a couple of times and they had to fix
it through the first time.
It blows up.
That's going to be a tough sell for tickets.
After that it takes a hit and it blows up.
It takes a hit.
But yeah,
if it doesn't blow up I would do it.
I just wouldn't want to be on like the first mission.
Although the first mission may be the best one.
Right?
That might be the only one.
Only one.
Yeah.
Well what scares me more than that,
it's the people that are willing to sign up to go to Mars.
This is more than a hundred thousand people that are willing to sign up for the
one way trip to Mars.
But,
but,
but imagine if I would say on that list though,
if you started weeding out through those people,
there's probably like 10 people you'd want to say it at least,
you know what I mean?
100,000 you know how many fucking drunk people are like,
I'll do it.
I don't know.
I think they have to like really look over the applicants,
make sure that it's something,
I mean if a guy's a Roofer,
you wants to go to Mars,
go,
hey bro,
there's got to be any roofs.
Well we have,
we're going to need roofs to need room.
Real good at work and had a,
that's like a God.
It's another really funny thing this guy used to work at told me about that
movie Armageddon to bring it up again.
But the premise of that movie is it's easier to train oil drillers to be
astronauts than it is to train astronauts to drill.
It's like,
you know,
we could do is why don't we just treat,
treat these astronauts with,
Yup.
Just teach about it.
Use it.
Drill.
Those movies have a special place in my heart too,
because that's where like Aerosmith started doing ballads fucking cell phone.
You guys are,
I'm back in the saddle again.
Like what happened?
What is this?
I can't help it.
What happened?
I couldn't help it.
What's going on with this?
Why is this song making me develop estrogen?
That one.
Yeah.
There's a few of those that just make you go.
How do you guys where you guys were the shit that happens?
Yeah.
I grew up in Boston,
so Aerosmith Smith was flushing that went to school pass and they had a,
what'd you go by?
Bu They had,
um,
uh,
a band that they used to pretend I,
they used to go to like a mama.
Ken was their place.
They used to show every now and then you hear fucking Aerosmith came by last
night and they would,
they'd be on the list as like,
like lizard feet to it.
Like whatever.
They'd make up some band name and then they'd show up and do you know,
they show up and do like a quick fucking,
that's fucking thing.
I never,
I never had the experience of seeing him,
but friends would show Perry them.
I sent text messages to carry.
That's very good light.
This is the crazy shit.
The coolest thing.
Text Message Joe Perry,
that's fucking I once when,
uh,
not as cool as that,
but I once was the daily shows at global edition.
So I used to produce this and I would go to Sony music was our edit bays.
So tons of musicians would be recording homes there.
And I mean like Jimmy Page,
like Robert Plant was saying.
And then when it like all sorts of crazy shit and I would hear it whenever.
So one day I'm there doing this edit for the show and I was like,
you know,
in this dark room when I go to take a piss in the just the Sony bathroom and
here
and it's fucking Steven Tyler taken up.
Not Yeah,
it's taking a piss and like green lizard pant like Leopard Pants and whatever,
like super tight like flowy shirt and,
and I guess that he was warming up his voice,
but it was so,
you know,
it's like the tile,
it's a bathroom.
So he's just leaning in the urinal and I was like,
oh cool this.
And I like,
man,
I it up now.
So I'm like,
what's up man?
You know.
So that was like my big Aerosmith experience.
I was like Steven Tyler warming up his pipes in a year and really cool.
Wow.
That's fucking awesome.
It's so weird when you meet all your,
saw Paul Mccartney one night at the Improv.
I didn't get a chance to meet him,
but just seeing him,
did he see you do stand up?
He was in the audience wants their La,
our audience warm up guy once,
didn't show up to the daily show where it was late.
We're awesome comic,
great warm up guy.
But uh,
was late so I didn't every now and then I would do warm up.
Like if it was an emergency situation,
I just go out and do warm up for the crowd.
And I did it one night when Springsteen was there in the crowd and uh,
she was sitting off to my right with his son Evan,
who is a great dude.
I know and a couple of his but Evan's buddies and he just like put on a hat,
sit in the crowd,
like love the show,
super cool.
All the like legends of Springsteen Shit you hear like book.
So I do warm up for the crowd and then afterwards I saw him,
you know,
he was talking to John after the show and I like went in to tell John something,
like I had like made something up.
I was like,
I have to tell John this thing cause I like wanted to fucking meet Springsteen
and uh,
he's like,
all right man.
He's like,
that was awesome.
I'm like,
really?
You know?
So I always joke around,
people were like,
well,
you know,
Springsteen and I are mutual fans of each other.
I mean,
he saw me,
I like the lady in the fur coat and I think he knows what I'm capable of,
you know,
would be,
that was to me the coolest.
I really said if like if I died the next day,
I told my family,
I go,
just so you know,
if I happen to die soon,
I'm cool.
You know what I mean?
Like it was pretty cool,
man.
I had to hear him laughing over my,
and he said something like,
Oh,
I thought you were going to come after us.
We're all wearing like flannel shirts.
I'm like,
oh,
it's just trying to burden you weren't there,
Mr. Spray said
no thanks Mr Mr Ass.
Very cool though.
Like when you meet somebody who you like on that level where you're like,
Holy Shit,
like I listen to your music and it's pretty exciting.
You know,
the biggest one for me ever was gene Simmons came to see one of my shows.
Gene Simmons brought his family and his son and is short.
That was the,
it was a new year's show too.
They come up,
he came up talking afterwards.
I was nervous as fuck.
I had to address it from the Kroger.
That was a huge kiss fan when I was a kid.
I mean it was everything really didn't even like other bands.
I just like kick ass crazy when I was looking at the revenue years old didn't
like other music.
I was such a ridiculous kids fan.
That's so funny.
That scared the shit out of me.
But Paul Mccartney for some reason maybe even more nervous.
I find that like working in entertainment,
musicians and athletes are the two groups that I get really nervous around
athletes.
I mean,
I'm sure of course you have,
you've work in the UFC,
but it's like meeting a professional athlete.
Uh,
you know,
like you see look their physicality.
Oh yeah.
Like,
especially when they're like currently playing the game and you go like,
ah,
like,
oh so cool dude.
Like you'd be playing on Sunday know like I get,
I'm like a little kid even though I'm like older at this point than professional
athletes,
which is like,
one of the harder things about watching sports for me now is when like you're
watching like a race.
Like I remember the Rangers play offs.
Like some we'll get on the ice and be like,
look at this 35 year old who can still tie his skates.
You know,
you're like,
Jesus Christ you the like,
can you believe old man knee buckles can,
I'm like,
I'm 37,
man.
What the fuck?
How old am I?
Like,
you know,
I'm retired now as an athlete.
You know?
That's why it's weird when you see Bernard Hopkins.
Bernard Hopkins is 49 years old.
He's a light heavyweight champion of the world.
Jesus Christ.
Fuck yeah.
And beating young guys like really good guys.
That's crazy.
Yeah,
he's incredible.
You know what I mean by that?
Things like that.
You're just like in awe because it,
there's something about what they do that is so beyond your bike comprehension.
Imagine you'd be on the court with Michael Jordan as he's fucking slam dunk and
it's trendy and see him leaping from the three point line flying through the
air.
You'd be like,
what?
It was an honor to get dumped on by you.
Mr. George has to be there.
I mean,
I don't even mean planning is standing there while he does it.
It's crazy.
It's absolutely crazy lies.
The different level of athleticism.
He said there were superhumans yeah,
I have that give you a pill and all of a sudden you could do it.
Michael Jordan would that you would be like,
you got a superhuman body,
like your Spiderman or a,
I mean that's the thing too is like when people talk about Oh,
comedy,
like why do you want to do comedy?
I was like,
I don't know.
It's kind of funny growing up and like I was like,
if I can make a living doing this,
that'd be cool.
But if I was good at baseball,
fuck dude,
I'd sure as hell wish I was like,
he's a funny guy in the locker room.
No,
I wouldn't even be the funny guy.
Maybe I would just be good at baseball.
Like in other words like that would be cool.
Like I would definitely want to do something that,
that if I was given any physical,
you know,
steps whatsoever
whatsoever.
Did you play any sports growing up?
I played like soccer and stuff,
but I was never,
I just never care.
I was weird.
I was very,
I was definitely like the wise that I got in trouble a lot,
like in high school on the soccer team,
like my coach will be like,
oh,
but he's shut the fuck,
you know?
And I would like get a little bit of play time if we were winning.
Here's something,
you know what I mean?
But I was good.
I,
I dunno,
I like never,
sports just weren't something I love to do,
you know,
I wasn't like into them.
Uh,
uh,
I like watching them,
I guess,
but I wasn't never like chicken.
I always know you wanted to be a comic.
Yeah.
I always knew I wanted to do like what year would you like it?
I don't know.
It was just the kind of thing where like,
I dunno,
I was,
I remember being a kid in me and funny and like just being in school and I,
and,
and I,
John Oliver and I used to talk about this all the time because he and I are
almost a,
we're a month apart in age and he grew up in England,
but having these weird parallel life experiences across the pond from each other
or like he would,
we were talking about being in school and a teacher saying something that was a
perfect setup for a joke and you knew if you yelled out the punch line it would
crush.
But you also knew you would get in trouble.
And it was like,
no doubt in your mind.
Like I'm going with the punchline,
fucking no decision to be made.
Yeah.
Go to the principal no matter that fucking kill member,
like a great one from school.
You have one cheese,
said something to a teacher and you're like,
oh shit.
I'm trying to think.
I mean,
I used to do stupid shit like in Spanish class,
like a teacher would call on me to,
uh,
for the definition of a word.
And I,
and then I would just,
you know,
like sock car.
I had ones with it.
I got my,
she called my mom about this,
my Spanish teacher saw car.
She was like,
you know,
go around the room and point and say,
where do we have to use it in a sentence?
And she pointed me,
she said [inaudible] car.
And I was like,
after school I have soccer practice.
And there was like huge laugh fucking principal's office,
you know?
And I was like,
was that kind of Shit?
Whatever.
And then like a call home to my mom,
like he's disruptive and my mom being,
you know,
but it was like,
to do that.
He was funny,
but it's disruptive,
you know,
I have,
what could be construed as a racist one from high school was that I had this
black math teacher who was really aggressive.
She and her defense.
We were terrible students and nobody was paying attention,
but she was,
uh,
she was like aggressive with the way she communicated.
It wasn't fun.
And uh,
this is the example.
So for whatever reason she decided to,
she goes,
um,
she was doing some thing on the board explaining some problem and then,
uh,
I was talking and she goes,
Mr Rogan,
would you like to come up here and do both of these problems for the class?
And I said,
would you like me to do both of those problems?
Oh Shit.
And she kicked me out for that.
But I go,
well,
well well that is exactly how you said it.
Right?
But what did I do wrong?
Let's explicit explain what,
what are you doing wrong?
You're a math teacher.
Doesn't speak English,
right?
Yeah.
And they kicked me out and everyone was howling.
They were fucking,
that was the only laugh I got in all of high school.
Really?
That wasn't funny at all,
but I,
I was,
I was easily annoyed.
How'd you end up going wanting to do comedy though?
Cause it's such like a s self loathing company.
He's a different card athlete.
You are good at athletics.
You know like what I'm on.
My fear came from a different place.
I mean everybody has like a certain fear,
you know that like leads you into comedy because there's always the a bunch of
factors like this one does.
The being ignored as a child,
that's always a key factor.
And then the fear and for some comics it's like the insecurity is what leads you
to like it propels you to get past the fear of going on and doing public
speaking.
And the whole idea behind it.
But my fear was like actual physical violence that I was involved in fighting
from the time I was 15 to 21 so I was scared all the time.
I was always terrified.
Like before I retired from competing,
my life was a series of getting ramped up for competitions,
getting through them,
relaxing for like a few a day or a couple hours and then being terrified of the
next ones.
Crazy.
So like all that fear led me to like have like a gallows humor.
Like I was the guy that we would be on a bus going to a tournament and I'd be
cracking everybody up.
Right.
But it was just cause it was terrified so that that's like that's how I got into
it.
But I never was funny in high school.
Like when I,
when I just had to say this cause this chick was a cunt.
This is the best part about it.
Like as I was leaving,
she will get called not saying that she goes,
go ahead and laugh cause Mr Rogan is going nowhere in life.
That's funny.
So what you can't say that you're teaching a class.
You can't say you're going nowhere in life.
You're a shitty role model.
You're a shitty person to be instructing a class.
If you speak badly and I have,
I'm mock you or speaking badly and you kicked me out of the class.
That's just saying that I got you.
Yeah.
So you know,
I've found like I remember getting in trouble for stuff like that.
Like I had one where,
uh,
we s I used to wear a hat to school everyday.
Like,
I was like a big thing when I was in baseball hat,
like a baseball cap because the door,
like you thought,
you know Sinatra,
God,
I wish I had the balls to warn the front.
I
remember like gay starter game hats,
like th that was like a big thing and like,
you know,
he's like curl the shit.
I still do it with my hands.
Like I call him around so much now or,
yeah,
you got it.
But now everybody wears them flat,
you know,
I'm not talking about it.
I can't do flat.
Seems silly.
And uh,
but so one day a friend of mine,
this girl,
this black girl at school had like a heroin,
you know,
like she had hair weaved in and she was playing with it and like,
like I was,
I was talking to whatever and I,
and I pulled one app,
I was just like,
fuck around with her or whatever.
And I had an associate,
she was laughing,
so I put it under my hat and put my hat on.
So I had like pay us like a Hasidic Jew,
right.
And then I just walked around school.
You know,
people were thought it was funny,
like I was the idiot where I pay is out of my hat.
That was like this girl's hair weave and she thought it was funny.
We all thought it was funny,
but then the fucking librarian at my school saw me and fucking annihilated me.
It was like dad is like,
cause he thought I was being like racist culturally antisemetic like she went on
a list and I was like I'm a Jew and like the girl,
she gave it to me.
Like I was like,
there was only that,
we're just trying to be funny,
but like those kinds of things I got,
I would get in trouble for,
see that's ridiculous.
You shouldn't get in trouble for that at all.
That's an asshole teacher.
Yeah,
but you were,
that was the librarian,
but she wants to snuff all the fucking humor out of the world.
And it's one of those things where you're like,
oh yeah,
it was just,
I was just getting some laughs between class and I was like,
no.
I was like a big,
that was again like I used to get are we talking about earlier about the over
sensitivity of the world and that it's where huge issue in universities now it's
a gigantic issue,
isn't realistic over sensitivity.
This not based on intent,
it's just,
it's based on demonizing words or ideas.
But this is also what's weird about it.
I think about this all the time.
It's like the left wants everyone to be the same.
Like that's the goal,
right?
Like no,
it doesn't matter that he's black or that he's this like,
it's like,
it's like we're all,
we're all just people.
We're all just this.
But it's like that's what,
when you start to like homogenize things that way,
that's what starting to happen.
Like with corporations,
they're doing the same thing where it's like you go to a town,
there's no restaurants,
there's Applebee's and there's like,
you know,
it's like we're,
we're making everything the same and like there is a weird part of that where
like what one thing that's nice about different cultures and hanging out with
different people.
It's like,
that's why I love being a standup.
Like if I hang out with like Latino comics,
like then like they're ripping on me for being like a white Jewish guy and I'm
like ripping on them for being late to like,
I don't know that but has never,
never racist.
It's just like,
it's not racist to have fucking hair if you,
if you decide to put,
how can she can,
she can have a hair way,
but you can't have a hair.
We decided to wear your hair long.
And she said it was,
cause I may pay us out of it.
Like I made it,
like I was making fun of Jews and I'll say,
no,
I am a Jewish.
She's like,
you're not that kind of do.
And I was like,
ah,
fuck fuck.
She's telling you what kind of juice,
you know,
look when you're 17 you just like whatever.
Like that's like if I started wearing it like a tank top with like spaghetti
stains on it,
they'd be like,
you're not that kind of Italian.
Yeah.
Now I am.
You could pull off with Spaghetti,
stay in tank type.
They fuck man,
you can't wear hair weaves.
I mean,
Look Dude,
this is 20 years ago,
so you know,
I don't know.
It was,
look,
I'll tell you right now,
if it was now,
it would be like on Fox News probably
nationally.
But you went to school like when it was fuck man.
People used to get like,
I'm older than you though.
And when I went to school it was less of an issue.
But did you ever,
like you grew up in a time where a coach would like slap you on the ass if you
did a good job like that can do that.
You can't do any of that kind of fuck the kids dying is the shame.
I used to blow so many teachers.
You know,
there's a lot of things,
you know what I mean?
Like you know like there is a weird,
you never thought about it.
It was never like a evidence of evolution.
Yeah,
I do.
And in some ways,
in some ways I think that we're getting,
we get hung up.
I think people get hung up on the eye as much as I think it's evidence of
evolution.
I think there's a lot of people,
like you just said,
you had someone on the show who believes Adam and Eve's a real story.
Like that's,
that's a problem.
You know?
And that's a big problem with when we were talking about how do you solve these
issues and nice guy.
Other than that.
Sure it is.
But I'm saying not even a dumb guy,
which is really weird.
But when you talk about solving issues,
I think we,
in this country particularly,
we've run into,
oh man,
how do we fix this?
And then you get the left going,
well,
we're gonna give them all money.
You're like,
all right,
slow down.
Let's not get carried away,
but give him all the money.
Like let's just figure out what are very hotel.
Yeah,
no,
exactly.
Yeah.
But then the other side of over the extreme other side of the really religious
side is like,
not just,
you know,
Neil and whisper into your hands and that'll solve it.
You know what I mean?
And you're like,
oh wait,
that's not an idea.
That's just a make belief thing.
Did you hear about the plane situation where they were going to El out El Al
going in Israel and they won't sit next to women beer.
Super Orthodox Jews puts the story.
I was fucking crazy.
Crazy.
They made them,
they got on the plane,
then they stood in the aisle of the flight.
They wouldn't sit down.
They got on the plane and they told them that they had to because their
religious beliefs,
they had to be together,
that people didn't want to switch seats so they couldn't rush.
You're showing that they can't be next to a woman.
I mean,
talk about like of reality of religion,
Judaism,
Christianity,
Islam,
they're all,
I mean like they're all really abusive to women,
man.
Yeah.
That stuff's pretty crazy.
Well,
Islam and and,
and um,
Judaism,
Judaism or their ancient man.
They had none of the ancient but there.
So,
and I don't know enough about this.
It's like something,
I'm a bit talking about wanting to write a bit that I got to work on and find
all that.
But there's a lot of stuff about them that are similar.
Like they don't eat pork once called kosher one's called [inaudible].
But like,
like they both speak this ancient guttural desert language with these weird
alphabet.
A lot of beards cover up your women and you start going like,
is there a chance that you guys are all,
you know,
maybe you know the,
the Koran,
I think there's five books in five bucks.
I was at la,
there's a lot.
And it's like,
is there a chance they may be like one guy heard it wrong.
I mean,
you know,
it'd be like you'd both telling the same story here and like there's like,
maybe you don't,
you don't hate each other as much as you think you do like crazy things.
They look alike.
What,
well that's what I'm saying is there is a,
but there is a component to that where you start to just go like,
look,
we got to give everybody with the proper respect,
proper tech,
proper respect.
But it's,
I have a very difficult time accepting the fact that I fucking spend money to
fly to Israel on a plane and there's a fucking dude standing next to me praying
the entire flight.
Like not okay with that.
This is not your fucking house dude.
This is a public space like fuck off.
Like what do you mean like that?
That's just not okay.
And a law was like the flights they paid for the flights.
They bought their tickets in advance.
They knew they weren't going to be sitting next to only men.
But it's like if there's a guy,
there's another photo that,
a link on that article you're about to read that I saw the other day.
There's a guy wrapped in plastic,
a Jewish guy wrapped in a big thing of plastic,
like a dry cleaning bag.
Cause he can't,
there it is.
See Him?
No,
because he can't fly over a cemetery cause he's a co Hayne which is the ancient
Jewish tribe of like elders and leaders.
That's like the name Cohen.
People were named [inaudible].
That's like a Jews.
That's Cobain.
That's like you're from the the ancient Jewish king and you're so special,
you're,
you're double chosen.
So he couldn't fly over a fucking cemetery.
So came wrapped himself in plastic because some fucking rap.
I was like,
no,
you just wrap yourself a plastic.
Really?
That's okay.
That's the loophole.
Rapid.
Well how about the loophole is like hold your breath.
You know they have a fucking law about flying over.
If you can't go,
you can't go near a cemetery.
So theoretically I,
if he can't,
thousand feet is not foreign allowing.
Listen,
Hey look and you would think you're so close to God in the clouds that you can
just say to him,
hey dude,
is this cool?
But how is the plastic bag and a protect you but your clothes won't know.
Well it look messy.
Yeah.
That was my favorite part about it was the rabbi was like that.
That's my favorite thing about religion.
I talked about my standup up times,
like with Judaism,
like some of the ideas that were good ideas like Judaism,
like they're trying to think of like what is this religion?
Like,
what are we really trying to do and won't go like what?
What should be our thing?
And one guy was like,
how about we cut baby penis tips off?
And they're like,
that's a fucking great idea.
That's a home run idea in this fucking religion.
It's,
it's bad.
Like it's,
it's same thing with that dot.
Just wrap yourself a plastic like who's making that shit up?
Well at least there's only one guy wrapping himself in plastic that everybody on
that plane had their dick cut.
It's probably 90% of what other debts on the Jews,
man that's on the cheap buddy now.
I mean it's preposterous.
So they try to sell that as some sort of a medically necessary procedure.
Actually it takes away all of the sensitivity of your penis is what it wants.
That,
that's too sensitive.
Now you want the foreskin back?
No,
I would take some more off I if I,
if I can.
Oh No,
you should.
You're saying your 2 cents.
Yeah,
I see what you're saying.
I see your problem.
You should wear really rough underwear like that gets not hemp underwear.
That's funny.
Burlap,
burlap sacks,
tidy burlaps get some tidy burlaps make them out of a potato bag.
Nice and rough.
He's really shapes up.
You're really fuck a fucking carpenters hand.
Make a banana hammock out of like some fucking burlap sacks that'll kill you
right up.
If you look at condoms,
a lot of the condoms have lotion on it too to help with the sensitivity.
So you last longer.
They're trying to do though.
I mean don't they try to make it feel better?
That's exactly the opposite of what they do.
They claim extra sensitivity,
condoms or that's the number one selling point is that they're more sensitive.
That's why they have lambskin ones like Brian,
I've never seen a condom that is designed to Numb your Dick Up.
Is that real?
They got dictum in in.
That's not the norm.
The norm is the opposite.
They have different,
all different kinds of,
Trojans has a four pack that has four different kinds at one that has ultra
sensitive one that has numbing,
one that has seen the numbing,
but that's kind of itself kind of takes away all of them.
You don't need the numbing.
I can see people have is that it's not sensitive enough.
That's the number one complaint about condoms.
It's not the,
you didn't,
you want to Numb your dick up inside the condom.
Totally.
I've never even heard of that.
I think that's why I don't use a man.
They just make me so mad.
You make you numb,
comfortably numb.
Um,
I mean I'm not saying that it doesn't exist,
but I would be really shocked and I think that's not the norm.
The norm is the opposite.
I'm sure it exists just in the,
in the market of,
you know,
yeah.
Most people were premature ejaculation.
Yeah.
Most people would want more sensitivity especially.
With a condom for sure.
This is a weird one is tier one is a more known,
a common one is durocs directs performance condoms,
which has a chemical inside it that's 5% bins.
Oh,
cane inside the condom to uh,
so it doesn't decrease your partner's enjoyment,
but it helps with the,
uh,
control climate,
climate control.
Is that really what it does is it numbs a tip your deck benzocaine.
Like our cousin of Lidacain isn't it?
Which is a cousin of cocaine shit.
But yeah.
Yeah.
A lot of them have that kind of stuff.
A lot of them really,
I can't imagine that that's common.
I mean,
even if it's one or two,
that habit.
I would imagine the vast majority are doing the sensitivity,
like trying to make it more sensitive.
I actually read recently that magnums aren't really bigger,
but they're like marketed that way to make guys feel good about having a worm.
They are bigger.
That's a letter.
I don't know.
I've read that like they're like,
they're not really as big as thick yellow,
so the guys would be like,
yeah,
dude,
I went,
man.
An ultra magnum.
Yeah,
that's for guys who actually have big,
giant hug.
Huge Hodge.
Ridiculous.
I can't even buy it.
They won't even let me buy it.
I can't even look to go.
Come on,
dude.
We'll be doing playing games.
She can.
You know the old joke,
don't waste your money.
It was one joke that everybody had.
God Damn it.
It was one of those premises that everybody touched on about buying my magnums
and box rubber bands.
Please stick their Dick and then Robert van on the bottom of a tighten it up.
Hockey ring it down.
Another one's a Trojan extended pleasure,
which makes you numb at one guy and the reviews on Amazon says made me so numb.
I couldn't feel a thing.
I had to remove it and rinse off just to get feeling back to my penis.
Wow.
But that one poor dude that came,
it comes like a hundred times a day.
Have you seen that guy?
Yeah,
he had a bulging disc.
He had a bulging disc in his back and something happened and he has like
literally has a hundred I got a lot like urban legends,
you know where it lives up the street.
I swear he's friends with my cousin.
He's friends with my cousin had it comes at funerals and shit.
Really?
Yeah.
He broke down in tears when he was talking about it.
It's Jesus Christ.
He broke down in tears and then the tier hit his cheeks and he came,
came immediately was making me come and it was a hundred orgasms a day,
breaks down in tears on this morning.
I guess that's the TV show as he reveals that it's ruining his life.
So how,
how did it happen?
He had some sort of a weird injury and um,
this is a woman that has nonstop organic,
too much of a good thing.
Wow.
Look at him looking at her like,
I seen this dude,
so dude,
where's the Gal?
I just want everybody to see your face.
Yeah.
Then maybe it wouldn't be funny if this guy was trolling is from Wisconsin and
so he's,
he,
he developed this,
a persistent genital arousal syndrome.
That's what they call it.
In September of 2012,
after slipping a disk in his back while getting out of a chair,
Jesus Christ,
speaking on Itvs this morning,
the father have to explain it.
It's completely changed.
Everything I've ever done.
I can't do anything.
I can't get a job.
You have to understand that in America 90% of jobs are service industry and
nobody would ever put me in front of their customers.
So working is pretty much out of the question.
So he's just commingled time.
I mean,
that's what I'm saying.
Like,
how do you come that much in a day?
I don't even know.
Well,
this guy's a weird looking dude,
man.
He's got fingers.
His fingers are all tattooed up.
He's got,
um,
like across his finger,
his knuckles are tattooed,
which I always used to get a job.
I always think when a guy does that,
like he's probably a little on the per fishing into Microsoft Excel.
Ah,
Shit Dude.
You know what?
We're going to keep looking.
Thank you.
See a problem.
You just come in my office.
I don't know if this is true because a producer could come up to this guy and
ask him a question and he could get on the television show.
And how much vetting did they,
do?
They mean,
do they follow them around?
Mean you can come a hundred times in a day.
It doesn't even make sense.
Yeah.
It sounds like he just wants a reality show.
He could be right.
Yeah.
Despite suffering from a near constant erection.
Mr Mrs. Decker rarely have sex.
Occasionally we will.
But it's very frustrating for both of us.
I've tried reading about it,
tried going to doctors,
but no one can help me.
I don't know what I'm going to do.
I just want to get my life back.
I just want to get,
but what is the,
what does the medical explanation of how it slipped disc can cause that?
That's a very good question.
I don't think it exists,
you know,
I don't know.
Uh,
according to medical literature,
here's what it's saying.
Trauma to the pelvic nerves can trigger hypersensitivity in this,
uh,
in this area,
the pelvic is painful.
Pelvic condition has left him household,
housebound and isolated.
They'll fear of suffering a public orgasm through fear of suffering and public
orgasm with even,
um,
some even causing him to drop to the floor.
Imagine you're coming so hard to drop to the floor.
Can I?
This is,
it's just called coming,
right guys?
He says there are different incentives and there's different intensities.
He says the ones that calls me to drop to the floor feel like all the muscles
from my chest to my thighs have gone rock hard and everything just seizes up.
It hurts and it feels good.
At the same time and you have all these things running through your head as they
happen.
You don't want to be around anyone and you don't want anyone to see it.
She's explained must nap a ton cause just coming all the time.
Do you ever have real blue ball where it actually hurt?
No,
but I had a dog once that I brought to the hospital cause I thought he was,
I thought he was really injured if that something was wrong,
you have blue balls,
cure that triangle.
Remember Frank?
He was going down the stairs and uh,
as he was going downstairs were
like going,
walking down the stairs.
He was Yiping Schick.
You Okay Buddy?
Come on.
What's the matter?
And I thought like he had broke his hip or something and he was like an agony.
So I carried him,
I picked him up,
I put him in the car and I drove him to the vet and the vet checked him and he
was,
he was wagging his tail events office and walking around,
he seemed kind of normal and I was like,
I don't know what happened.
He was going down hills and he was,
um,
he was an agony was Yiping and the,
the,
the vet checks his balls,
he goes,
look at this.
So he had balls,
hit balls,
he had balls,
he has his balls,
but then in front of his balls,
his dick had extra balls.
He had these swollen glands on his desk.
It was the weirdest shit ever.
He's like,
he had an extra set of balls on his dick.
So I go,
what's going on?
He goes,
you got,
uh,
there's a a bitch in heat and your neighborhood.
That's an actual textual term.
It's called a bitch.
And He,
and he goes,
uh,
and he's freaking out.
I called,
that's incredible.
Like he's so horny that he's in pain.
That's crazy.
He goes,
yeah,
he goes,
uh,
it makes sense if he's going downstairs,
you're just a juggling of your balls going down the stairs and he's a pit bull.
I mean he could take all kinds of pain.
So I can't imagine the ball pain.
This poor guy was then brutal.
You just said a lines from it.
Two live crew.
He a freak without warning.
Cause
I actually had it once and it was the first time I ever made out with that porn
star used it.
The first porn star ever dated and it hurt me for like hours.
Wow.
Simple Cure.
It'd be off in the bathroom.
She won't give you check off and I'm saying you didn't know that that was the
cure.
I mean it's well documented.
Shut the door,
lock it.
I meant literally from driving home to a house my first time meeting her,
I remember pulling over go,
oh wow.
Never had that happen.
That is,
that's crazy.
That's a hot bitch.
So it happens.
See,
I now use bitch in the wrong way.
That'd be careful.
You're doing it specifically to teach a lesson so that the kids listening.
Yeah,
for the proper way for the kids.
Take about dogs.
Can you about what they go through it.
Don't let it happen to you.
You can.
He handle things.
They can't do anything about it.
I remember kids,
if your dog has ever whimpering,
first thing you should try to do is jerk it off.
I had a friend who said George's daughter off.
No you didn't.
Yes,
I did.
And how he's a jerk.
His rock and he used to jerk is rottweiler Wolof.
Which foot he would put,
well he would say that the dog was in agony and he would help him out.
So He'd put his foot on the dog's Dick and just rub it,
squirt all over his stomach.
Uh,
Bob Barker Fan of like getting your dog neutered.
You're not into that.
Um,
well my dogs are neutered now.
I have two male dogs.
They're both neutered,
but I don't think it's necessarily all the time.
I think that the,
you know,
people are concerned about prostate cancer and certain things,
but my doctor,
a doctor,
Craig's a veterinarian,
um,
he didn't believe in it.
He said,
you don't need to.
He goes,
if it's irresponsible to let your dog breed with other dogs,
he goes,
but the testosterone that like,
like when a person has their testicles removed,
um,
men no longer produce testosterone and they get really depressed and he's like,
your dog will have less energy.
He's like,
it's just,
is what's going to happen.
They will,
they will lose muscle though.
Their body slims down and they'll probably have less energy.
And he's like,
it's not popular to say he goes,
but it's a physiological reality.
Yeah,
yeah.
It's,
yeah,
it's definitely getting your balls cut off.
Um,
you know,
there was a woman that there's some really controversial,
um,
experiments that were done with dolphins in the 1960s and seventies and it's got
John Lilly,
John Lilly is this a famous psychedelic pioneer.
He's one of the guys that he invented the isolation tank can actually,
and he was this guy who was a,
he was working on interspecies with dolphins and he set up all these experiments
and one of the experience he set up,
this woman lived with a dolphin and by lived with it,
I mean the dolphin was in a tank of water with the water was up to her waist and
she lived with his dolphin.
She would walk around with the Dolphin and like she would sleep there,
she would climb up on a bed and she would sleep on a bed.
But like what she was working when she was doing,
she was in the water in the water constantly.
With this dolphin and the dolphin would get really horny so she would jerk off
the dolphin.
And that was a big part of the controversial behind these experiments because in
her mind she was like,
look,
he was young,
he's male and he was really distracted and he couldn't concentrate on the work.
And the work was,
they were trying to teach the dolphin,
try speak English and they were trying to teach it how to say human type noises.
There's a,
um,
there's a radio lab,
a podcast about it.
Uh,
I cry,
I'm trying to figure out what that masturbation about this very case by case.
It's incredibly fascinating.
And uh,
I had always known about Lilly because I think it's called hello?
Yeah,
it's called hello.
It's um,
it all is about the,
the uh,
the issues with interspecies communication,
less crazy dolphins.
They kind of understand the concept but they can't make the noise cause they
have a blowhole.
But this lady was trying,
she was living with this thing for a long time,
but she was jerking the dolphin often.
Then there would they,
I still train that and lily was doing acid and try the cut off funding or you
know,
it's like I respect that the the effort,
but at the same time that,
right.
And how long have you get another dolphin?
You know,
maybe you just have to,
you don't have to live with the dolphin.
Yeah.
I mean there's gotta be a better way.
I think they were concerned.
Imagine that Dolphin was the fucking happy.
I can't imagine it was like,
this is great.
I'm living with a lady.
I don't know if he thought it was bad.
I mean we have this big hangup about sexuality,
but imagine if you had an itch on your back and you couldn't reach it and you
know,
you were being taken care of by someone and they scratched your back.
You're like,
oh,
thank you.
I just mean I would always lean towards like put the dog down from,
yeah,
I mean I'm,
I'm more of a don't jerk in animal off kind of a guy,
but I just mean there's,
my point is,
well then maybe get a better facility to keep the Dolphin and get a couple of
dolphins live.
Put them in a,
I don't know.
I mean,
you know,
anytime you have an animal in captivity,
it's pretty fucked up.
But I don't know that jerking him off is the right way to do it.
If you know she's totally run.
What'd you do?
Which was if you had to choose an animal,
the jerk off,
which is not a,
you know,
a lot of people ask me this question,
I would not do it at the monkey.
Cause if you do it wrong then bite you.
I think do it with a monkey would be a little bit too much.
Like just doing it with a dude or a rough and he was like about a monkey and
they just fucking suck the teeth.
Your thumb,
I don't like how you're working the ball exotic.
I'd go like giraffe right now because it's tall.
You could stand,
you know,
but they might come and kick you in the head.
They buy.
Look,
there's always a risk.
There's always a risk when you're an
executive producer.
The daily show was
died jerking off a donkey.
I think it's a terrible way to go.
I just wallet bear cause they're so cute.
Do you know they rape a lot?
Yeah.
Really love bears are famous for raping each other.
Well,
there you go.
They're vicious.
They,
when they fucked they bite and really fucking get crazy.
I did not know that.
Yeah,
you don't want to jerk off qualities.
That's what I'm saying.
[inaudible] you
need to sleep on this.
I'll let you guys know.
Yeah,
let's,
uh,
let's put this to a test.
I mean what she did was ridiculous but only ridiculous by our cultural
standards.
If you think about it like biologically,
the real issue biologically is,
you're right.
Like they shouldn't have a dolphin in captivity with that.
That's all in the,
uh,
the podcasts.
He started document why they did it because it was,
it's really hard to communicate with dolphins and the wild.
Yeah.
I did this thing in Hawaii recently where we went swimming with a dolphin.
I had my four year old with me too,
and she was in the water like right next to me.
I literally,
I was holding onto her while we were swimming and she's got the scuba mask on
and shit and she's,
you know,
snorkeling,
looking down.
Well,
the dolphin swim underneath it.
It's amazing.
Yeah,
it's amazing.
And they're wild.
These are not like sea world and they'll,
they'll sonar you.
It's fine.
They'll get near.
You aren't,
they'll make weird noises and shit.
I like that.
The lady,
every time I talk to Carter to Maya calculations,
he's saying jerk me off.
I've just to him,
I mean we don't know that for sure.
Trust me and I speak to off and he wants to be jerked up.
It was apparently is really a leg.
It was humping her leg.
It was like,
all right,
that's just reached down there.
Give him a handy and then back to work back to school.
The Dolphin was never going to able to speak PR human.
I think it probably easier for a personal learn how speak Dolphin for sure.
We can very well they have a blowhole man.
They're not making much sound out of that fucking thing.
I also think at some point,
you know there's no real need to speak to often.
That's a very good point.
You know what I mean?
I mean,
in other words,
we know they can communicate with each other and like that's fine.
You know,
we could use them as weapons so,
well obviously you already,
they already did the navy's done that.
They did.
The Navy did something with dolphins dump bombs on them.
Fucking ships yet or do a word it like blow up mines or something.
They didn't use it for anything.
Sure it,
how crazy is that,
man?
Yeah,
they're really smart too.
That's how they're really smart.
There's a dark thing that we do and keep it off.
If we were Mirman that we,
that would be man's best friend.
You know what I mean?
Like I've lived in the ocean,
that'd be dog.
We don't have dolphins.
Imagine if they looked like people but with tails.
But there were all the same color as a dolphin and they did breed there.
So they came out for air and,
but we didn't understand them cause they spoke like dolphins.
Would we be comfortable if they live the exact same life would be comfortable
with them in captivity then?
No,
no,
no.
But imagine if they look fucking song with blue skin and a fucking beard and
they had arms and shit and a human face.
But they would have talked about
shit out and they lived but they didn't have,
I don't think probably might be a way to work around it,
but I don't,
I don't think it'd be that easy.
I'm getting,
I'm literally getting a call from the syfy network.
They want to do it.
They said yes it would if it looked a little bit more like a person.
Yeah.
Like it had a mouth and apes in captivity.
Which row issue point apes,
you know,
doing all sorts of shit cause we try out lipstick for the longest time.
Bronx Zoo.
Was that to say that a black guy and the zoo?
The Bronx zoo?
Yes.
They had an African for short period of time in the Bronx Zoo.
When,
when was that?
I think it was like the early 19 hundreds.
She says.
Yeah,
yeah man.
Well you learn things like this.
It makes you not feed the African.
Yeah,
it was crazy shit.
His name was Ota Benga.
He was a pygmy and uh,
he was,
uh,
wow.
Um,
he was,
this is really crazy.
He was known for being featured in an anthropology,
anthropology,
uh,
exhibited the anthropological anthropology exhibit in the Louisiana Purchase
Exposition in Saint Louis,
Missouri in 1904 and in a controversial human zoo exhibited exhibit in 1906 and
the Bronx Zoo.
Wow.
He had been freed from it.
Uh,
an African slave trader by the explorer Samuel Phillips Varner.
Now getting to this zoo cage,
he traveled,
he traveled with this guy,
the United States in 1906 two.
That's just not that long ago.
Yeah.
At the Bronx Zoo.
He was exhibited in the zoos monkey house.
Wow.
Whoa.
I mean to,
to be fair.
Whoa.
Holy Shit.
That's,
well,
they,
they would file their teeth down.
That's like a part of their culture and a lot of those,
that is scary.
It's crazy.
Well,
that's not that long ago,
man.
That's all I'm saying.
108 years.
Yeah.
That's fucking nuts.
That's scary.
Weird.
Yeah.
That's going to be like another hundred years.
You'd be like,
you ever got that lady dropped off the day?
What can you believe they let that happen?
It's just weird when you see these sort of things that happened not that long
ago and we looked at it as baby in a zoo,
African girl in human zoo.
Oh my God.
What year was that?
Uh,
I find out that is,
it's fucking cocky shit.
It says throughout that late 19th century and well into the 1950s Africans in
some cases native Americans were kept as exhibits in zoos as late as the 1950
[inaudible].
Well,
you know what we were talking about early about the evidence of evolution or we
should probably say progress.
They hate,
it won't say evolution.
You talk about human progress,
like thinking it's not really evolution and evolutionary is bylaw biological
term,
but human progress,
like there's pretty clear evidence that something's going on and the in this
abandoned men of retard and these words,
we don't want to let go.
Ultimately it seems to kind of be moving in to better direct.
Yeah,
I would say that anytime you're resistant to that stuff,
it's,
it's an impulse to like,
fuck that I'm not taking it,
but then the reality is you're always kind of on the wrong side of history.
Right?
If you don't at some point go,
I actually understand that there's a group of people who associate themselves
with this term and if makes him feel like shit,
if I say it and you know there's going to be ones that I came in on and once I
probably don't and I was like,
you know,
become more mature.
I try my best,
you know,
like I get it.
If like you've a kid with down syndrome,
you don't want to hear me call something retarded.
I totally get it.
Yeah,
totally.
You know like the word fag is a word that I used to say like I didn't think it
meant anything,
but I don't ever,
I will call it the f word now.
I really do.
I just said it now and I realized it's been a long time.
God,
it felt so good.
So you did.
You did dude.
Thank you very much man.
It's a fun podcast.
Yeah,
I had a blast with you guys.
Thank you so much man.
I really appreciate it.
Big Fan of this.
This was extremely fun for me and cool for me to do,
so it's fun for us too,
man.
You're fucking hilarious.
Anytime you want to come back.
I appreciate it.
Yeah,
no,
I'll be was good.
All right.
Well I've got a [inaudible] going to be at the stress factory.
Awesome.
I love that club in uh,
October 17th and 18th and I'm a New Jersey in New Brunswick and then I'm going
to be working on this new show for comedy central for a little while doing these
gigs around Manhattan.
But my next,
like my last kind of like headlining Gig is that the stress factory from this
shows the Neal Brennan show?
No,
it's the ones with Larry Wilmore.
Someone taking over for Cole Bear.
Oh yeah,
you got a full minority report.
Awesome.
What does that start?
It starts January 19th.
That's when it's on TV.
Yeah.
It's going to be totally cool.
Different show.
Let us know.
We'd be happy to tweak that and promote that and you guys are the best.
Thank you.
Twitter is Rory Albany's,
eight L B a n e s e r o y.
And come out to the stress factory,
man.
It'd be fun.
Thank you guys again,
Nori,
Rory Albany,
Albany's.
I like,
I use the dollar.
Sign your name to ball,
you know,
come see me.
The stress factory.
Hilarious.
Standup comedian.
All right.
Thank you everybody.
We'll see you soon.
Big Kiss One,
one,
one month.